the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
kings were crushed and ponds were
punished at the super United rapid and
Blitz in sagreb Croatia players who
started slowly were ready to hit the
ground running in front of a crowded
playing Hall following a rough start
two-time world champion Challenger Yanda
ponyachi went on a heater winning all
three of his games to catapult into
Coley but the story of the day was the
collapse of reigning world champion
Magnus Carlson who lost two games in a
row only to defeat tournament leader
viswanathon Anand in the last round
there's a three-way tie for first who
will pull away from the pack day three
of thrilling chess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back chess fans to day three of
the super United rapid and Blitz held
here in beautiful Zagreb Croatia It's
the final day of Rapid chess and the
players will be looking to put their
stamp on the tournament through
scintillating and beautiful chess let's
go to the studio and start the ash
the granchester returns to Croatia it is
reputable detection with the greatest
players in the world our live coverage
from the San Luis chess club and Zagreb
starts right now
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us I'm
International Master nazify kids and I'm
here with my brilliant co-host yes
it's been so much fun a great calling
the action with you and Mero I I'm
loving it I agree and it's pleasure to
watch all the games I know they've been
great hello everybody and welcome to our
live coverage I tell you it's been
Thrills and Spills Galore an
unpredictable event who could have
imagined Magnus losing back-to-back
games and then taking care of business
with Vichy and Nan to allow a three-way
tie for first my goodness uh we're we're
breathless uh tell us about the current
standings let's take a look we have
three co-leaders Fabiano Carolina
with eight points and then only one
point behind young Christoph Duda and
the youngster from India gukesh and our
number one seed struggling at 50 percent
oh my goodness hard to believe it truly
is and tell us about the format
we have a 10 player round robin
tournament in the rapid time control is
25 plus 10. in the blitz it will be 5
plus 2. in Rapid there's a double
scoring system two points for win one
for a draw and zero for loss in Blitz
there will be a traditional scoring
system and the players are not allowed
to offer any trust with two days of
Rapid under our belts tell us about the
remaining schedule right today we have
the last day of Rapid we'll see around
seven to nine and starting tomorrow two
days of Blitz will finish on Sunday but
we might have playoffs if necessary
absolutely a mirror I tell you it's been
fun to call the action with you too
Welcome to our studio tell us about the
road ahead for the players uh thank you
very much yes and Nazi and everyone
welcome to the final day of the rapid
let's not forget not the final day of
the tournament still there will be Blitz
but the one who wins the rapid usually
well positioned well to win the
tournament or unless take the Vestal
with three players died for the first
place let's look what's gonna happen to
them in this final day Fabiano caruana
always somewhat different tournament
Destiny but well positioned to win the
rapid portion and we will start with
vision answer today he will have to play
Young Christian of Duda gukesh who by
the way just one point behind any the
final round he will play his co-leader
for now janipomnishi
then for Fabiano caruana the opposition
doesn't look any easier it's Google
machine round eight and then in round
nine it will be alireza feruja
and for nepo who by the way did amazing
comeback yesterday with three
back-to-back wins he will play against
Ivan sarich and then consecutively
against Fabiano caruana and viciana
and while we are waiting for the games
to begin let's hear from Zagreb
Christian Anastasia what's going on in
Croatia's capital
thanks Miro and welcome back chess fans
to the final day of Rapid here in Zagreb
Croatia and water tournament we've had
so far a yumiro highlighted three very
impressive players but let's not forget
about the former world champion Magnus
Carlson because we know what he did in
Poland and he was in a very similar
situation he had a rough time in the
rapid portion but after that trailing
behind by the way going into the blitz
portion three points behind Jan shisht
of Duda and we know what happened in
Blitz in Poland he scored plus 10
actually obliterated the field and went
on to win the tournament so you can
never count this man out but I have to
say yesterday Anastasia a very very uh
strange moment happen tell us a bit
about that yes Magnus Lost first all two
games in a row which doesn't happen that
often to him right I mean he's one of
the best players in the world and it
doesn't happen that's much and then he
lost this game against feruja and
everything happened so quickly that I
think he didn't realize sexually at this
moment so I think it's better to watch
it first and and we'll discuss it
I think that's just residency
and you and there's the handshake and
it's Magnus uh we do not say this very
often as Magnus loses back to back two
games
and look at the there's a kind of a look
of shock on magnus's face right he's
listening to Big Applause for furusia
from the audience but look at him he is
just he's a taser like he he's missed
something
Pro
Frozen
you are actually there in the playing
Hall how did the atmosphere feel yes I
was there I was one of the spectators
let's say and and really I was also
shocked that everything happened really
quickly and let's say at the beginning
nobody could understand why he's Frozen
why he is stuck for so long and he was
just standing there and like I didn't we
were making photos and videos and later
on I published all of them in our social
media accounts many people of course
noticed this moment and they were
discussing it trying to guess what
actually was happening with Magnus at
this moment I really think that he was
going through all these lines and
variations which just happened and he
didn't really have time to realize all
of them and you know what also surprised
me that he didn't put the pieces back to
the starting position this is his habit
this is what he always does you know
attain a game and I think that was very
emotional moment for him and kudos to
Magnus for you know striking back and
winning the next round again we shall
not in the last one absolutely
spectacular moments spectacular audience
as well clapping after every single
round is just an amazing feeling here in
Zagreb Croatia and we are just about to
start day three guys back to you in the
studio thank you Anastasia and thank you
Christian Thrills and Spills Galore with
more in store
do the honors Nasi tell us about the
round seven pairings coming up let's
take a look we have Richard report
playing Magnus Carlson
lupulasco playing alireza fieruja sarich
playing one of the tournament leaders
janipomnishi another tournament leader
Carolina will be facing that's a great
game right there and of course Anand
against Dura another one very important
to our standings the players are
fighting hard what are they fighting for
they're fighting for a lot of money
there's total of 175 000 in prizes the
first place winner is going to win forty
thousand dollars second place thirty
thousand third twenty five thousand nice
price fund all the way to tenth and
final place of seven thousand dollars 13
Grand Chester points if you win the
tournament is a clear first 12 if you
tie and one of our leaders Fabiano
getting ready for battle is uh he's at
the board very happy to introduce a
young lady Emma
she is 15 years old she's a four-time
Croatian Champion among children and
Emma is going to be making the opening
first move in one of the games which one
will she pick
maybe even search
[Laughter]
that would be a good local Choice uh for
sure and I tell you uh the the number of
decisive games has been great but it's
not just the decisive uh game numbers
it's the games themselves the quality of
the games remarkable and really really
uh unpredictable results like a number
of games you could have imagined either
side of winning or losing them as we'll
see the number one seed Magnus
uh back-to-back losses but he did meet
vishy in the housing
so he's not thinking about yesterday
not at all and Vichy uh Miro jumped in
now what how do you think Rishi is
stealing he's lost his lead but he's
still there uh right Lisa is well
experienced enough I want to say for
this kind of tournament so hopefully he
had good rest and and ready for battle
uh it'll be tough for him considering
the opposition and this game might be
crucial because Dura is just one point
behind
indeed sorry to say I missed Emma I was
told that she would be making the
opening first move but she didn't
uh apparently we didn't have that
footage there as okay we have an open
Sicilian night or on the board going to
play Queen D3 again nope Bishop E2 it
served him well in his world
championship match in
1995 New York City we were in the Twin
Towers and mayor Rudy Giuliani on 9-1-1
opened
the event yeah it was great who wasn't
on playing that much
that was the PCA the professional chess
Association and let me just bring
rishi's game up as
um Miro I mean first of all we're not
seeing that many open Sicilians to begin
with it's like the players are ducking
uh the lines and Bishop E2 E5 Knight F3
also okay very very standard but uh
this is opening choices as we've been
seeing with white against a sicilian a
little suspect uh well I don't know it's
uh you know perhaps our knowledge of
what's considered to be classical uh
Sicilians is getting a bit outdated yes
I'm looking at at the database and what
do I see a current position of the A4
had seen Carlson playing it and then
constantly and then Wesley saw and so on
and so forth even though yeah if you'd
ask me like the combination of Bishop E2
and Knight F3 does look a little bit
suspicious right but that's that's what
they do nowadays yeah last move Queen B6
still still we are still in a theory
even though we've lost Carlson games and
now the highest rated is the Shiela Graf
from from what we have the shell grave
in 2017 played it against Jeffrey Sean
Queen B6 a kind of a page out of the
poison Pawn uh is he really going to
grab that for example if white were the
castle you go Queen takes B2 is that
yeah let's let's find out yes and in
fact Castle's Queen takes B2 apparently
famous black
wow so yeah what computer has is the
main line is to actually attack the
queen and invite the capture then to go
Bishop D2 and now this queen starts to
feel a bit awkward and yeah black has to
drop back a long id5
after this yeah well a lot of moves with
the Tempe and actually it might be the
critical line and the Knight takes
King takes black is up a pawn but
perhaps his position is quite dangerous
why it's going to go Knight D2 and then
uh looks for Knight C4 Castle short F2
F4 potentially this is a dangerous line
so I'm wondering after A5 here if it
will be played after Queen B6
uh similarly there is no way back right
right A5 you you don't really play Queen
C7 you just uh
yeah just lost the tempo so he has to go
for this seemingly dangerous line and we
have rugby one instead
not A5 not Rook A3 but Rook B1 and I was
considered in Rook A2
Rook eight okay uh Rook B1 is still a
part of the theory no no it seems to be
the first independent move and we have
H6 by the way yeah H7 H6 uh by Duda I
want to turn our attention uh quickly to
the game of Yvonne sarich versus nepo
nepo one of our tournament leaders
because this too is an open uh Sicilian
again a night or but this time the
English attack with Bishop E3 unlike
Bishop E2 and against E7 E5 the
traditional Knight B3 as opposed to the
Knight F3 Retreat that we saw in vishiza
game and they've been following the most
theoretical line known in this line in
this opening exactly and it is thousands
of games in this position double edged
whoa whoa
yes exactly 92 and it gets it gets crazy
with after Knight A5 there's an A5 A4 a
line that goes forever too it's like F4
and F5 my goodness but G takes F6 and C
takes Queen takes Knight takes Knight A5
Queen E8 the players are playing really
really quickly it has almost 27 minutes
two minutes on his clock and Miro bring
us up to date on the theoretical uh
dispute what's going on yeah so well to
give you a rough idea how well started
this line is you're absolutely right
that g takes F6 is a rare move and by
Rare I mean it's well roughly 500 games
only
compared to what you mentioned Knight E2
which saw almost 3 000 games please
right so gf6 and yes they're blitzing
out because they are still in the theory
and from what I can see well a couple of
games of mixing with Shiela Graf with
black and he is considered to be one of
the Knight of Specialists right right
visionant against Alexander grishek back
in 2011 so more than 10 years ago this
was already played on very high level
and that's it for now yeah so Queen E7
still
quite a lot of games I have to say I
would expect Queen A3 in this specific
moment because you're eyeballing what
would happen after Queen yeah so there
are two theoretical moves Queen A5 for
whatever reason is much more popular
okay and you can play Queen A3 as well
Rook to C6 is what black is uh Queen A5
was real already
it didn't allow you even to consider the
response would be the same Rook to C6
right like plans to dabble on the C5 so
now it seems to be like a main Crossroad
in this specific line because uh up to
six different Maps came to B1 Rook to G1
Rook to D2
uh well but yeah speaking of Statistics
I think black does relatively well here
it's funny because you were mentioning
six moves and I was expecting you to
suggest the move that I want to play
with white and if I wear white shoes I'd
be tempted to play H2 H4 with the idea
of meeting Rook C8 with Rook H2 because
I do in time want to be able to play
double my Rooks and for the moment I'm
leaving my Bishop behind and I don't
know maybe I want to play H5 but uh very
sharp Theory you don't listen to you you
played H4 which is a novelty which is it
is so good
it's so good H4 is that theory two uh
it's a novelty yes sir it's a novelty
and there is uh you're absolutely right
Rook to H2 seems to be like a nice idea
for
a nice idea for white however well compy
says that Knight H5 at some point okay
you start with that then Knight to H5
and then some Knight G3 potential yeah
so black is not without a chance
relatively equal but that's always what
computer has to say exactly it's so rare
that we start a around without looking
at Magnus Carlson's Games first I mean
because you know we like to uh look at
our tournament leaders but Magnus isn't
one of them okay what is it he's up
against Richie Rapport and Richie played
the Russell limo with Bishop B5 E6 and
97.
uh very standard stuff Knight G6 C3 and
it's funny it's sort of like uh French
defense you know pops up or the
appearance of a French defense uh pops
up on our
um
uh
game board
with E5 and advanced now
because the Knight is on on G6 already
you're not going to put your knight on
F5
you're almost obliged to play F7 F6 here
absolutely if you if you delay it too
long the Knight on G6 is going to be
like a a target for the H Pawn G3 h4h5
so I make I don't know if this is if
we're still in theoretical Waters but uh
both players are playing quickly mirror
so I'm going to suggest they're in their
prep uh they might be because there are
still games for this position including
the last move which was played which was
Bishop E3 widesmith uh I don't know yeah
black is still thinking yeah well if we
are to speak of key moments in this game
when he has played Knight G6 when Magnus
played Knight G6 he pretty much accepts
this uh French structure because
yeah after C do C3 you can't really play
D5 immediately because it's a bit too
much so you have to play Bishop E7 first
and then we are getting to this
uh blockade French structure here
actually white starts with Knight C3 and
white into the capture right and only
then goes E5
uh much more popular instead of Knight
G6 to go D7 D5 right away yeah by a huge
margin like almost 800 games compared to
Knight G6 being 90 games only and for
the current position on the board
computer tends to like white but um yeah
it's hard to tell it's not a big
advantage and sometimes maybe it can be
explained simply by white having a bit
more space you know so computers tend to
like space yes
me too and their matchups Nasi how did
they do against one another
what didn't see this coming wow they've
only played 10 Rocket Games and Magnus
won seven of them that's a good customer
I mean that is a very very Richie wants
to break that Trend my goodness oh I
didn't see that coming oh and seven uh
terrible in fact uh check without our
other tournament leader Fabiano
absolutely
and let's see what this looks like it's
coming from one of those
Joko piano games and uh
you know when you play A5 yeah
it's like
Everybody Plays with both colors he says
some people play with A5 others with A6
gukesh goes with the A6 the traditional
uh way of playing h2h3h6 B4 now this is
really something I've noticed more from
Wesley so Wesley has been kind of
playing it in these slow ways with a B4
and queen C2 and rookie one and Bishop
B2 and well okay I guess I'll be yeah by
the way everybody studies Wesley so
these games too right so Bobby says cash
is well prepared too he has still 24
minutes on the clock he's playing very
very quickly yeah Bishop E3 takes takes
and again uh
it's very deceptive it looks like
everything's quiet and solid but in in
fact
um the the the the strategical
[Music]
um
it it's so sharp even though it looks on
the appearance on the surface of things
nothing special is going on I think it's
always misleading because 16 phones are
on the board right and things can
can blow up like that and by the way for
good cash day two was really a good day
as he's coming out from two victories uh
Bishop takes E3 rookie three throwing it
over to you Miro uh what's the consent
oh sorry you've got the other game we
can we can what's the consensus of the
Fabiano's position with goo cash right
so they've left the theory not that long
ago believe it or not yeah after 13
moves you can still find games of one
Magnus Carson with white and some other
players right Knight G3 happens to be
the first independent move even though
it's very standard for this kind of
positions right D5 Bishop E3 Bishop
takes Rook take
and uh you were right it's very hard to
assess those positions but like the pawn
chains and you can it can shape any way
of form uh interestingly I was told by
Alexander grishek who understands the
thing you do about you know chess in
general and Jacobian Italian in
particular that uh you don't want to
double those pawns if white can play A4
and B4 if you remember at some point
black switched to a7a5 instead of A7 A6
and then they can happily do this bishop
E6 thing and here according to grishek
once again uh well white must be
slightly better that's that's what I was
told the computer tends to agree but
even though the lines it provides are
underwhelming it's also why it's better
because of this this and this it's like
you play rookie one and you're slightly
better perhaps of because of the pawn
structure so it's a long long grind I
believe uh C7 C6 on the board Miro is is
that a standard move I want to say ask
yeah well perhaps it's it's actually for
me it's it's not that easy to understand
why would you play C6 here because
you're never planning to capture with
the c Pawn right right so after after
rookie 3 computer has as the critical
line it actually has D4 right and then
he takes he takes and Rook to E2
rookie and then Rook will go to C2
perhaps if Knight F4 is played and this
was roughly equal of the C6 tends to
favor white slate slightly but I think
it it's too early to draw any
conclusions if I may I'd like to switch
to nepo's game please by all means right
because couple of minutes ago a couple
of moves ago computer was very happy
with what he was doing so after yasa's
novelty H4 well let's not go too far
Rook F2 H7 H6 for now right I don't know
if black needed but perhaps he needed H7
H6 and then the very next move sarich
played happens to be a mistake so b2b3
and then NEPA goes with D5
and I'll have to ask for help from an
engine minus two to comprehend why it is
so strong right and and the critical
line should be at capture on D5 of
course right Knight takes and then Rook
takes that would be my naive version of
what can possibly go wrongful and then
you take
and if Queen takes it turns out aha so
that's a funny tactic here a check here
and Rook 2 D6 wow so D5 wasn't a threat
but since white played B3 he made it
yeah weakened this diagonal made Queen
A3 possible and that's very common
pattern in chess yeah you typically
blonde the Tactical idea which was not
there before your last move right in
fact after D5 Evon played King B1 right
worse yeah maybe you should have played
King B1 initially and not B3 absolutely
yes after after d takes E4
it's just better for black black perhaps
just wins upon so what computer gives us
the follow-up for why it is to capture
only five ef3 and just play this
position it's black is a phone up and
still has some attacking potential so is
things looking good for Nepal and it'll
be his fourth in a row if he wins wow
wow that's impressive yeah
um just uh turning the game uh farusia
from for a moment this is the E3 nimso
Indian for uh White by Constantine and I
something about this move Knight D5 I
find this move very attractive because
at this exact moment there's no E4
you'll take and play Bishop takes and
you'll understand that the move Rook E1
preps E5 and after B5 I want to see your
reaction after this live yeah it's it I
like it it shuts uh White down I I've
played in my career uh Dutch stone walls
but I never had such a good Bishop as
the bishop shut it down can white still
play E4 well let's have a look scene uh
E4 tags Bishop takes and now we pause
for just a moment
by the way you didn't have to take you
had Knight F4 option as well which
looked quite attractive
you're you're right Knight F4 uh would
uh in this case take over Bishop
probably Bishop drop back Bishop drops
back
IDs of E5 I'm
more or less I want to take the spawn
yeah
it looks good but uh how to follow up on
this uh so I think because of the Knight
F4 uh
yes and maybe he'll play E4 next move if
you take with the bishop exactly
if I take with the pawn then you'll drop
the Knight on E5 so taking with the
bishop looks right e forward takes takes
now I'm not really afraid of Bishop D5
but the question is I want my queen The
Black Queen to get somewhere like F4
would be H5 would be good too but a kind
of an ideal Square I don't know Queen F6
that looks good okay I don't like why
it's Bishop on B2 no it doesn't make a
good impression at all you probably want
to play again something with not Queen
C2 and 95 intriguing uh game going on I
want to go back to the Vichy game
because uh Vichy versus Duda this was
the queen B6 if you remember we got this
Rook B1 on the board a move kind of took
us by surprise we were mainly focused on
A5 but Rook B1 was vicious Choice H6
Queen C6 attacks the pawn on e4 Knight
D2 and this reminds me of the game
between Vichy and sarich from yesterday
where you remember we had a queen on G3
that went to F2 okay Knight C5
Rook A1 I don't know about you guys but
that's an indication to me that White's
not comfy Rook A1 castles Bishop F3
castles B5 it feels like uh dude us for
Choice here I I don't know uh I'm I'm
not a fan of vichy's play uh what says
the engine uh Mira right you are right
you are yes Rook B1 and then Rook A1
fails to impress yeah and I'm wondering
if nasi's Rook A2 would have been better
at least the a pawn would be protected
in this moment right I mean after 95
imagine this Rook when I do at least you
can Castle but maybe you're running into
Bishop E6 anyway for the current
position of the queen E2 well computer
was suggesting to swap the Rooks and
probably go before next move but even
after Rook a to B8 it's really awkward
for white okay to White well perhaps
remind us some you know some measures
like go before
and then black has a funny trick to jump
to B3 because now C3 Knight is hanging
and yeah some really wild complications
like Knight goes to D5 right it takes
over here believe it or not because
after he takes Quincy to all of a sudden
black holes even though it looks
dangerous right the Queen's almost
trapped but no you can't do much
and the rook and A1 is hanging too right
yeah oops that wasn't the intention
returned all the way back
and we've gotten another move from vishi
which is Rook F to D1 and here ah black
just has to has to play the Sicilian
move Rook C8 right and gets quite a
serious pressure so we she maybe did not
recover fully after yesterday's loss
well one player is having a tough time
with the white pieces as well as uh
Yvonne sarich as this move D5 is uh by
nepo when he got that move in b2b3 being
a mistake B3 followed by King B1 it's
almost like okay play King B1 first and
then you can decide whether you want to
play Bishop C1 or C3 or B3 but B3
allowed this D5 and as Mira was pointing
out there's this beautiful tactic of
Shaq and Rook D6 after capturing
everything on D5 King B1 there goes a
pawn there goes another pawn and with
that capture too Knight
um G4 Forks everybody
Bishop to D4 to to keep the knight from
going to G4 there's a made on G7 Queen
D6 rook and already a very big Advantage
can never win another Pawn with Bishop
F5
wow if he can do that I was thinking he
was going to go Knight G4 or Knight E4
exactly but you like Bishop F5 and
uh does it win another Pawn if I play
Bishop D3 I take Bishop takes D3 which
he just played I think Bishop F5 he did
yes you have to take with the c oh Rook
takes you oh you you're thinking Rook
takes I now here maybe I'll just play
after
first
yeah well it looks terrible uh Bishop F5
and nepo cruising uh he claimed he
he complained to Anastasia breakfast
yesterday that he was looking to win one
in a row
he made it three out of three and this
looks like he's making it four out of
four picking up eight points in the
rapid uh Miro this uh
suddenly nepo is on a roll uh right so
completely winning if you ask the engine
it's almost plus four wow more than plus
four guys in fact after Bishop F5 which
was the uh the most precise move and not
much I can say like if you look at the
engine suggestions sometimes deviliation
doesn't tell you much but if you look at
the suggestions of the engine to go King
A1 or King B B2 you understand
something's terribly wrong with White's
position yeah Bishop C4 was played and
now Knight E4 seems to be crushing
because well it's really hard to find
places for all the white pieces and well
it has to go Rook d8 Rooks gonna be
traded black girls King H7 now the F
Pawn is very dangerous already some
threats of capturing the bishop on C4 F2
94 moved very much uh played instantly
yeah the the tempo uh and that whole
idea of F2 and Rook takes C4 is very
compelling uh jumping to the game of
Richie and Magnus because that is a game
that's kind of slipping away out of our
purview after the move Bishop E3 I
thought Rook C8 and you you kind of
bring everybody and then you decide when
when you're going to play F6 uh Magnus
preferred H7 H6 G2 G3 and this is what
I'm talking about if white plays H5 on
his next term like just H5 and your
knight has to go to h8 you're crying you
got to get in F7 F7 so we did say Magnus
play Knight h8 yesterday voluntarily
exactly F6 takes Rook takes
Rook C1 Bishop D6 it really looks like a
just a very traditional uh yeah French
with 92. Knight comes back to E7 uh
looking to play Knight F5 and capture
this bishop
Knight E5 Knight A4 pardon me and Knight
C5 takes takes Queen B6 seeing a lot of
Queen B6 uh Miro uh and today's round
seven uh why is everybody like Queen B6
don't tell me because they want to win a
pawn uh well perhaps they do because
white has to what white has to do is to
play Queen D2 but you've identified it
absolutely right a white position is
better it does seem to be like a very
favorable version of uh the French
defense which moves like put it simple
Queen to D2 Rook to f8 well creating
some pressure and now I'm checking yeah
for whatever reason that that might be
hard move to find it's important to drop
the Rook to the third rank because then
yeah okay that's the reason when he
captures we probably just capture with
the Rook protect the Knight and it's all
going to be about the difference of The
Bishop's strength right the bishop G2
can go to H3 and the bishop on D7 is not
the active at the moment exactly when we
left it we didn't like vichy's position
that much and maybe it's not completely
terrible but after Rook D1 Knight A4
just think about everything they look
for in this opening yeah when you play
the Sicilian as black and you sit there
and you look at this position you go
well this is kind of a dream position
you as you're about to say be ideal if
you if you will the Rooks very nicely
positioned the extra Center Pawn Walter
Brown uh sixth time uh U.S Champion Used
To Tell me the the thing about the
Sicilian is you're better in the ending
I was just going to say that and this is
Queen C3
you're better in the ending I said well
why Walter is black better in the ending
he says well you have an extra Center
bomb and uh this is this is
not a pass bone it's a weakness in this
position well it's a weak pass pawn
and uh Mira what can you tell us about
the position oh wow it happens to be
that Knight A4 was perhaps selling his
initiative a little bit too cheap
cheaply when he went yeah when he went
Knight A4 because yeah I wish he reacted
in the right way
B3 ab3 cb3 and in fact nobody asked what
happens if if the pawn is taken right
right it turns out white is not that
unhappy because he's getting some very
annoying Initiative for the pawn so Rook
C1 you can't really go to the B file
because of some various pins and you
have to make some awkward moves like
Queen to E8 and then white captures and
goes Rook to A7 and then if white ever
gets the chance to activate this bishop
like get it to A2 G8 diagonal it's white
is going to be better so computer has it
as an equal position this one with black
being a pawn up and also black has to
play some awkward moves like Knight H7
or something so after Rook have to C8
and by the way by the way instead of
Knight A4 as we we discard just any
typical Sicilian move would keep like an
advantage group to E8 even or Rook to C8
Which is far more common
and in the current position yeah Queen
C3 was an option however white trades
and once again it seems if we trust the
machine it it seems not to care much
about the black taking on B3 says I will
defend with two Bishops right right so
Bishop f8 H3 let me pick at the
evaluation right now still favorable for
black but not as much as he would have
if would he play Rook C8 interesting
and just taking a look at vichy's day
ahead and who he's facing uh once more
at the opening of the show Romero you
were telling us about his opponents uh
that's kind of murderous row right there
I mean he plays his compatriot in round
eight but good fish is playing a very
good tournament yes sure he won two in a
row and he is looking good against Bobby
as well and then in the last round today
vishi will be playing possibly this Soul
tournament later after this round
exactly having one for
and nepo is uh enjoying himself I would
say he's enjoying the game very
confident that he's got this game in his
pocket well just the fact that you're
taking a walk during a rapid game
I don't think he's aware yet okay now
he's suddenly aware as he uh as he faces
a check uh quickly trades and King H7
and it's about that F Pawn that pawn on
F3 Bishop takes F7 F2 would be nice just
wanted to go to a fobby's game for a
moment because after the move C7 C6 I
kind of felt that Bobby was going to
reach for his a-bond maybe play the move
A5 kind of shut things down and grab
some space over there he went for Queen
C2 where's Lismore Wesley's move A5 Rook
B1 takes takes uh D4 Rook back so far
everything looks pretty normal and then
Knight H7 okay for me as white
I get terrified of these exchange
sacrifices Rook takes and then tonight's
coming to H4 and G5 yeah yeah H4 G5 even
F4 I'm not I would not want to do I
would not want to face those nights no
not at all
it wasn't no I think we had more moves
just a second what did he do sorry I yes
he did stop it uh Queen to D1 uh defends
the Knight but at the same time Rook F7
uh gukesh
he's the one
pushing at this moment because it's a
slightly worse Pawn structure but has
the initiative on the king side
but can he really start an attack right
so the first thing is the first question
I might ask is that if I
um The Immortal words of Jim McCormick
sees the defensive uh on the on the king
side I go
yeah Queen G5 and
more or less I wanted to meet that move
with Queen G4 the moment I trade Queens
I feel like you know uh no more
checkmates yeah no more checkmates
um maybe start with Knight F4 Knight F4
exactly so you don't have Queen G4
anymore exactly D3 is going to be
um
and this starts to feel uncomfortable
I'm not in time to play G3 and H4 yeah
I'll say this is definitely not the
position Fabi was hoping to get with
wife exactly uh on the other hand you
know Miro it's not like there there's a
terrible amount of weaknesses in White's
uh position but I do feel he's on the
back foot
well even though after Queen E7 engine
has it as an equal position right
Believe It or Not Right But it's equal
if you find the right maneuver because
King H2 is not that surprising right
very often you do this King H2 and
sometimes even Knight to G1 to protect
the H3 Pawn to go G3 but how about the f
file right you're not in time to move
the Knight away
Rook to f8 and here you have to foresee
that Rook G1 guards you against this
sacrifice no black sacrifices white is
not that unhappy he'll put the Rook on
G3 and well according to machine survive
and what he has done in the game was
Rook B2 very easy and then he is no
longer in time right he has to move the
Knight away Knight F4 and this is
annoying King H1 but it's it'll be very
hard to get rid of this Knight on F4
yeah you're not ready for H4 and G3 but
again at this position even though black
does look like he's enjoying the
initiative
um again white is covering
all of the uh potential weaknesses it's
very possible also for black to over
push here he's going to end up in a much
worse end game because of the pawn
structure easily yeah if we take the
Queens off the board I gotta Rook on D2
I'm suddenly playing Knight G4 and uh
whites for Choice uh in this exact
position mural King H1 I have to imagine
black has to find also some precise
moves because as Nasi was just saying if
you don't
you know hit directly uh on the head
here uh White could easily take over the
game Queen G4 G3 let's go let's go write
you on and in fact upon some
consideration engine sort of changes its
opinion right and then then goes for
something like C6 C5 wow and then he's
as white you would not be terrified with
the prospect that black opens files for
your pieces exactly Queen side right
right because otherwise yeah if black
let's imagine black does something slow
issue yes
it's still that White's not getting
somewhere too fast but Rook to F1 okay
and I don't know let's just pass with
black what's White's idea okay it's H4
and this is how he gets rid of the weak
Pawn on H3 so H4 the pawn can't be taken
yes of course I've made couple of silly
moves with black because now it's a now
it's a double attack right right okay so
this apparently how it works H4 in the
very next move G3 okay I'll waste one
more Tempo just to highlight how it
worked G3 and if white gets this this is
much better right so that's the conflict
is about this Knight on F4 being able or
not being able to stay there if it's
pushed away why it's better in any
possible regard yeah and cool cash
played like the engine C5 wow
uh again that's not an easy move to find
because as as you were saying Miro your
instinct is black in these moments is
not to help your opponents Rook on B
file being opened
just to remind everybody who's joining
us late uh we have three co-leaders Fabi
Jan and Vichy and bokesh is not far
behind so if he manages to pull a win
yes you LeapFrogs yeah now has Napa won
the game because when we left it it just
seemed like Yvonne had misplayed it
badly you're still going but he has like
four extra points on the inside
but they're not connected they're not
connected they're an ugly uh but there's
a lot of them when we left it we left it
after this move Bishop c494 Rook check
there was a trade of Rooks King H7
Bishop F1 so essentially
Yvonne is worried Rook takes C4 and F2
was on Black's agenda so after uh Bishop
F1 F6 Bishop moves G5 let's go those are
those are terrific questions should we
push exactly too many options wow okay
I'm a pond grubber but G5 takes H4 oh
there is a knight G3 sighting
Bishop to D3 F2 and yeah as four pawns
versus
yeah white doesn't have any King side
structure and by the way White's passers
over here winning his games with Sam
's 18 minutes on the clock he's playing
very very quickly and I remember Vichy
as a junior player all the way he he he
broke into the top ten and he was
playing classical games with having used
10 minutes
yeah and his opponent would have have
like no time on his clock he really he
really threw everybody off with his
speed this looks like it's over and uh
back over to you Mira what uh what
caught your eye
uh while we might get a win for one of
the participants he who did not win a
single game yet uh chances of
Constantino lupulasco looked better and
better
I think we you guys left it somewhere
here or maybe a move earlier right yeah
and then he was suggesting Queen F6
Knight B6 was one of the top engines uh
top engine choices as well as your queen
F6 and what happened next uh that was a
crucial moment so now uh blacks oh
brother
side structure Pawn structure is quite
remarkable right what you may argue has
an extra opponent on the king side right
majority while Black Sea Pawn is a
backward Pawn but with the bishop on B2
not being very active black has to have
good chances and up to the point it was
exactly that Knight C4 Bishop C1 and
then A5 interesting very tempting move
happens to be not the best so B takes
Rook takes and then Knight E5 supposedly
gives white
substantial Advantage I'm still trying
to comprehend what why is that yes
Bishop takes D takes Queen E6 and guess
what you've got the majority you have to
start pushing
F4 and then next move G4 and Rook slide
on the second Rank and and all of a
sudden white develops quite a quite a
devastating attack so farooja is in
trouble I have to say well that's so
surprising because if you looked at the
position I would say oh this came out of
an open Spanish that's an easy one and
the idea that uh White uh okay this is
the game of uh nepo versus Ivan sarich
but the the idea that suddenly uh white
with this majority that looks like it's
blockaded is is winning or better that's
shocking it's very hard to believe I
yeah black still looks like they should
be fine right but F4 with the idea G4 F5
and Yvonne tips his hat and says well
well done uh my my B3 and King B1 were
terrible
and
now I think he was at the well he was
certainly at the bottom half but I don't
want to say he was ever last but he was
pretty down he started with a loss the
first round
well let's take a look at uh nepo's
tournament this far so he was in last
place
he lost the first round then he drew the
next two he was in trouble in both of
them yes he could have easily lost that
four in a row is he pulling a magnets
yeah
well as we were saying plus 10 and well
nepo is a happy guy
um
Bravo let's just jump to Fabi versus
gukesh because uh Fabi understands what
he needs to do he's got to expel his
Knight on the floorboard uh when we left
it we had left it after C5
close the files we were just talking
about how it would be nice for white to
have an open file on the queen side yeah
instead of taking on C5 he pushed B5 I
guess it it's a timing issue from
White's point of view white wants to get
an H4 G3 expel this Knight on F4 and
then at his convenience take I think
there's something maybe he's afraid that
if he captured Queen takes C5 that he
was afraid that this deep Pawn was too
vulnerable as it turns out he played the
move B5 B6 H4 he's ready for G3 if it
doesn't please H4 blunder upon I'm maybe
missing something Knight G6 oh I was a
thought you were going to take it and I
was going yeah
uh Knight G6 so it's a double hit
because when uh Miro was showing us the
line Rook was on F1 White's Rook yes
white was playing Rook F1 first and so
and then in this case he could play G3
but he
F1 Pawn on F2 is just hanging so uh to
continue the variation Nasi H5 would you
come back in this case
let's see
is Rooker 4 sorry is Rook F2 an option
let's have a look wow no it's not I
don't have enough pieces left I will let
me show you why well I I don't think it
works uh sorry what would you do you
could go back 94 yes Knight F4 okay
well it's something
just a second D3 is okay so if I go just
for argument's sake Rook F1 let's just
uh see I think this is so now I I really
want to switch on the queen side a
little bit play C4 and queen A3 or queen
C5 oh that's nice I have my D4 Pawn is
just beautiful it truly is and uh okay
um
I'm you're making a Believer out of me I
think Fabi is still uh
let's say awkwardly placed a Miro jump
in please well you can't find a better
word to describe it awkwardly and yeah
so first things first like caption C5
was possible but it's not better than B5
let's agree on that and H4 happens to be
quite a serious inaccuracy
and not that white has kind of
distinctly better move here it's just
that it really allows Knight G6 and then
H was hanging f2's hanging so you pretty
much limited to H5 Knight F4 and not
only C4 ideas but Queen G5 is very
annoying because you're about to drop
the H5 pawn and what you would like to
do normally in this position is Queen G4
followed by G3 but then you're dropping
D3 right right so this is impossible and
therefore the whole sequence doesn't
work and you still have to play a move
like Rook to G1 after which this happens
yeah and this happens
and white apparently has some
compensation it's not -1 so it's just
not a pawn for good white has to go A5
and create some sort of content play
there but black is better right I've got
it I've got it guys okay after you play
the Knight to G6
I'm going to sacrifice upon
like once every year or two I do make
Pond sacrifices I'm going to play the
move G3 okay and you're going to take on
F2 it's because you want to shove my
knight backwards
back to AJ no Rook takes F2 Rook takes
F2 and basically I'm going to
congratulate you and say you know your
Pawn up but your pawns are double Pawn
it's not the worst thing that ever
happened uh in my life that these two
pawns on E5 and E6 and I'll just try to
trade off your active piece and I'm
going to say this Knight on G6 one day I
would probably keep the rule can go to
B2 right but you you feel where I'm
going with this that it's a pawn
sacrifice that you may not think
it's it's it's that great
um I'm going to play Queen H5
unfortunately we're not going to see any
of this any of this because played Queen
C7 no Knight G6 I think he's just
prepped in C4
it would appear to be the case no Knight
G6 if I play Rook C2
Rook C2 that's a a good preventive move
uh I when I see the move H4 I I
G3 Knight H3
oh oh
yeah Queen C7 I want to get rid of the
knight uh that was the whole purpose of
H4 I want to play G3 but G3 would walk
into Knight H3 right
um if I have three is your night trapped
it is okay so G3 we have it on the board
uh get rid of them that's interesting
what's that 93 sacrifice and C4 are my
pawns good enough
so it's not my game you can sacrifice
pieces so hold on you get upon you're
not going for Rook F2 you're going for a
peace sacrifice with C4
wow
uh Miro jump in on this one is uh
congratulate Nazi on being in perfect
form because Knight D3 gives black close
to the decisive Advantage no Bobby's
last move was a big mistake so after
Queen C7 it's actually shifted a bit in
White's favor and he could play still
just stopping the sea Pawn or even
according to machine once again just go
A5 probably creating getting some come
to play of his own and after G3 indeed
if Knight goes back to G6 is in White's
favor but right he has to find Knight
takes Queen takes go C4
wow companies indecisely where the queen
goes either F1 or D1 and in both cases
he just play D3 and you say well okay
this game has more than only nights
right I mean the pawns are Marching F2
is hanging it's very dangerous for Fabi
might be a big
it's to jump to C3 from H2 and then five
is good right well okay C3 is a big
threat how do you deal with that like
Rook A2 is one of the versions but then
green gets to C5
and then Rook to d8 so he's banking on
this pass uh pair of pass pawns so just
Rook to D at Rook to C7 it's not easy I
believe in the game when you have Rooks
lined on the f file right all of a
sudden to switch to this idea that you
actually play in the center and the
queen side so he might not find it but
if he doesn't find it it immediately
shifts in White's favor but on the other
hand cook has just played Queen C7 so I
think 93 IDM is maybe already in his
head and C4 push right uh well I was
thinking he moved Queen C7 press he
played it 1933 yeah that he he wanted to
play C5 C4 and now recognize that he's
kind of pushed into this sacrifice I was
thinking that uh the queen makes a
terrible blockader of past pawns so
instead of the move Queen D1
Queen F1
and I'm assuming D3 uh once again
can I hold you up with the move Rook to
D2
I mean I'm dreaming that this Knight on
H2 3 Rook D3 Rook takes F2 where does
your queen go
uh that's a good question
um H3 threatens Queen E6 with a check I
like it that wins upon maybe Queen C4 ah
you know you're a party pooper that's
not my fun uh on all counts but wait a
minute wait a minute okay so I'll I'll
continue Rook
or should I continue Rook to D7 and
queen G4
you think you have time for counterfeit
I don't know uh the C Pawn is uh
definitely scary okay but Rook uh Miro
we're getting mired in uh A variation
of Queen F1 uh clear the cobwebs how how
would the line continue uh well you'd be
surprised but exactly in the same way at
least computer claims it to be so D3
little D2 it goes Queen C5 nevertheless
attacks df2 Pawn uh you have to push the
pawn according to machine so perhaps
tonight let's just find out why 94 is
bad it's this followed by this
and if you capture its Rook takes Queen
H3 and C2 you give up the E6 Pawn as
well yeah it's not me yes I wouldn't
give up anything I don't give anything
yeah but but the machine but the machine
says remorselessly the machine says that
this is winning wow don't tell me I've
blunted the queen and no that that's
funny so check
and the thing is if you go here it's a
check again
thank you captures you're a queen up for
a brief moment but frukish one is a big
threat it's mate
yeah right so anyway if we are back all
the way here Queen C5 he needs to play
F3 and then black does exactly the same
so protects this pawn and it's
interesting yep black is what down a
horse for just the pawn and he's not
running yeah he's not rushing it so Rook
to D7 Rook to C8 so it's a huge position
of compensation because of those two
points exactly uh let's just bounce
around as the players are getting in the
time travel once again we do have one
decisive result I'm looking at the game
that mag Magnus Carlson I like Richie's
position three versus three but this you
know Pawn on E6 that's not making a nice
impression and Richie's last move I
really like rookie five he's looking at
Rook B5 and I don't know why it has real
chances I do I reverse color reverse the
players for a moment you would say
Magnus is in his element
Rook
coat so maybe be sure
Bishop I just want to exchange also
those Bishops
the desirable Bishop to D5 is just
walking is that right Bishop to D5 well
you would win upon I would a Walker
Texas
Rook takes E6 yes exactly so Bishop D5
would would provoke you to playing King
uh pardon me Bishop well I can sacrifice
upon it should still be a drawing okay
interesting
uh but okay Let's uh let's continue our
walk around Fabi we've just been
discussing pardon me uh for ruja well we
did see the move F4 it did get played
but it did not get followed up
because because of age five G4 stopped
it queen of three H4
G4 HG and farrugia is keeping his Queen
firmly uh blockading the password
what about you
me too as long as you're not playing F5
and E6 uh farouzia
is doing fine well pulasko just needs to
reverse Queen and Rook exactly then
black would be in danger if you could
play Rook G2 to G6 right uh hit hit the
queen uh marrow jump in uh right where
did it go wrong right you are so now
in the position on the board well compy
says it's equal but
I would prefer black if anything
Queen F5 and so on right yeah however
the initial assessment was correct so
after H4 could it be that he's forgotten
about and person yes sir I don't know G4
looks a bit straight yeah Rook F2 okay
Rook F2 G6 otherwise F5 is happening and
here they move to get substantial
advantages Queen G4 this might be a hard
move this might be a hard move to play
but once again if you trust computer
this is good if you take on A3 this is
super bad for blacks right two past it's
like what they say it's not the quantity
it's quality what matters so two those
two connected past pawns are perhaps
just winning the game the Knight is too
far right so E6 F6 Bishop goes in right
and after what he did over here yeah
Rook D7 was played instead of Queen F5
roughly equal
uh Interruption Miro we do have a draw
in the game between Richie and Magnus
just exactly the point where I'm saying
Richie has an edge
exactly uh commentator's curse once
again uh goddess uh sorry to interrupt
you because I just wanted to go very
quickly to the game of Fabi and gukash
because a lot of moves got played very
quickly they follow exactly our lines
yes Queen F1 D3 cool question and play
Queen C5 as Miro was suggesting he
played immediately C3 exactly four on
the board and here we're looking at Rook
D6 I think yes that was our line uh I I
was
contemplating both Rook D6 and Rook D7
the reason I was thinking about Rook D7
my queen on H3
terrifyingly bad I want to get my queen
of the game and if I play Rook D6 and
queen G4 I do have a threat you have
Rook D6 on the board by the way both
players under three minutes
uh was this right marrow
it's getting a bit shaky yeah so it's
getting there's a knight on H2 as we
already know C3 wasn't the best move but
the reason for that is is actually quite
remarkable so Rook takes Rook takes F2
so far so good Queen H3 you're
absolutely right Queen C4 and then in
order to keep the balance White had to
play G4 and that's definitely not the
first one and after G4 it wasn't even
yeah like Queen is joining to stop the C
pawn and what he has done in the game
Rook D2 once again it's a tough moment
because apparently the advantage is Rook
E2 and once again it's not that easy to
consider this map so now if yeah if
white trades he can take the pawn with
the check but then after King h
seven once again
engage seven to First force a check and
then to go to h8 because if you go to h8
immediately let me show you if you go to
change the media then Queen E5 is a huge
Temple Rook H6 is threatening and C3 is
hanging
so that's you know it's not that easy to
guess all those correct moves by the way
just to interrupt you it looked like
Magnus was fascinated by this position
as well but King H7 King H7 then king h8
of course those are really tricky
details and and even to consider rookie
too I believe it's not that easy so
exactly machine has it as better for
black but pretty much anything can
happen yeah instead of going to rest and
prep for the next game this is their
analyzing calculating this game you know
it's so strange I'm looking at Magnus
right now uh when I was playing in these
events with Gary Kasparov it was like
people would finish their games and then
just go to Gary's board and just you
know watch what was going on and I
remember one Olympiad where Gary played
Victor korchnoy Luzon where literally
you know 900 people in the playing Hall
who were playing their Game Stop to
watch that game
Soviet Union versus Switzerland it was
an amazing game anyway Magnus absorbed
by the game you say that good cash the
engine likes uh googesh's position
because of the move rookie too well
guess what he played rookie two and the
players makes a mistake King H7 but
again I mean how do you know yeah and
here you said Queen he takes E5 saves
white yes and then you go C2 roof check
King G8 and some Perpetual with Queen D5
and queen to the eighth rank that's
machine that's that's the correct line
so King H7 once again would have
if not worn but gotten black a really
serious advantage and then you go here
even play Rook G8 a passive move because
your C Pawn is too strong so once again
the Knight on H2 is not on time right
the C Pawn is too strong remarkable uh
sorry uh again we've kind of Left Behind
uh Vichy versus Duda nothing really took
place so we didn't really miss too much
in this particular game three versus
three the players appear to be drifting
their way towards a draw and uh the game
of farugia
uh well it's a mess
the clock is a huge Factor yes firusha
has only 42 seconds lupus got two and a
half minutes and a complete chaos on the
board right when we left it we were we
were complaining that White's Queen was
misplaced and that the Rooks needed to
be ahead of the queen well guess what
that was exactly what uh Constantine
managed to do he is Rook did leap over
the queen The Rook is threatening uh
Rook takes G7 and we have this position
on the board Miro help us out uh
they say it says still roughly equal but
it doesn't mean anything because you
know with such a short being such short
on time and yeah it happened so it
suggests Queen G4 for white yeah I was
about to say I really really want to
play the move E6 and F5 so desperately
yeah and black Black's only move would
be Rook B to E7
and then seemingly white doesn't have
much like you can give a check on C8
okay Rook to f8 capture the pawn
so so you're born up yeah and uh group
B7
and says it's equal crazy because yeah
perhaps whenever you get uh you know
like Breathing Room You'll Play D3 and
you'll have start having threats of your
own right and perhaps white really can't
uh join the game with the bishop right
so the bishop ones you want white
squeezes the maximum activity of what
what plays but Bishop from C1 simply
cannot join the attack and therefore
yeah you can see yourself zeros so means
blacks holding that's it to me the
position's not zeros
it's three results and I would be
shocked if somebody didn't win this game
uh I agree one of these players but
there's 17 seconds to a minute 14 and
Constantine used a lot of clock on that
move Queen G4 rookie yes you can have
some updates inside this game I think
five is playing for a win because he
gave up his Rook for that pawn whoa whoa
whoa instead of going for the Perpetual
track Queen takes E5 C E2 and he had to
prepare on the board he could have
played Queen d8 and made the Perpetual
he decided to give up his Rook by the
way just a quick visual of the two
queens here whose turn whose turn uh
Rook takes Rook takes Knight F3 and he
said well wait a minute I've got a
couple of Pawns and I've got a threat
he's got three pawns on tonight yeah I
like that I I understand why he might
have been uh so unless there is already
a Perpetual here for black I think
black's in trouble
well we just saw Queen C2 check I'm
imagining King H3 Quincy eight
ah Queen C8 does look like a Perpetual
ah because G4 would be asking too much
yes then Queen C3 Queen C8 oh thank you
good morning St Louis ooh that would be
lights out actually so I would have to
go back
okay so from fabi's point of view could
he try King F1
abstract Quincy
you mean walking into the PIN
oh I don't know me gusta uh he's insane
Quincy tree yeah yeah I'm not happy
about that I can't cross and it's a
Perpetual no no I draw the moment
commentator's curse again the moment I
told you it was an equal position and we
do have another game racing towards a
draw of Avicii it all happened at the
very end uh quick results and the
gookash game is still ongoing okay Fabi
found
away from perpetual and I do too
but he did give up one pawn and he gave
up on his Knight to G5 ideas but okay E5
from his point of view he's ready to
play 94 as well as E6 uh Miro jump in
What is the engine's assessment here wow
it's still a draw of course
right but if not for this petrol check
with Queen C8 a couple of moves back
right
white would be winning and that's the
problem analyzing with the engine
because you get you know like carried
away with this zero serious all the time
and then it turns out that in order to
achieve this draw black has to find a
few only moves So currently after E5
Queen to G4 or queen to D1 and this this
loses by the way the move he played
Queen A3 here here goes your draw right
so instead he had to bring the queen
into a zone of Perpetual once again it's
a queen G4 and then be ready with those
checks I see after Queen A3 E6 wins
E6 Rook E7 that's what machine says and
then just Knight E4 do you have it I'm
thinking that moment you establish the
Knight on G5 and you've got green
check made ideas
and he's played he said he has played E6
what are the clock Times by the way Nasi
uh 20 seconds for good cash and minute
and 20 seconds for hobby oh it's
significant that extra minute boy you
feel like you've got this luxury you
know this extra minute your opponent
only down to 10 seconds and Fabi really
managed to outplay him well this could
be a huge victory for Fabi uh again uh
Fabi would join nepo as a co-leader and
he's taking down
a very uh tough rival I want to say
glucash winning
two games yesterday still has to be
careful here this is the 95 queen of one
right yeah this is the drawing Zone he
can win The Rook by going queen d8 queen
DH the queen ending
well wait a minute
well you're playing 95 I think I have
Perpetual do you really Queen D.A check
King H7 Knight G5
checks and give me The Rook Queen F1 and
you're saying you hide
I was reaching for the G4 Square
beautiful drink by the way yeah oh okay
so it means that I have to give you the
night that's a Pity uh here I would run
the G4 happily Magnus still there are
still watching the game right yes if you
step couple of moves back after they
check on the second ring that's why
white had to play King F3 that was much
better and with the game he would win
right and now there's always some signs
some hint of Perpetual yes because of
Queen E2 check uh pardon me a queen
takes E7 Queen takes E4 on the board
Queen F7 was the only move which keeps
the position winning he found it yeah
and he's ready to run for the Hills
right King to G4 King to G5 oh I can
never take only six that'll be queen of
five check check and force in the queen
exchange precisely
you have it
Queen h14.4
exactly Queenie for Queen F4 if you
reach for the E pawn queen F5 rocks your
world yes forcing a winning King upon
ending so Queen H1 on the board King G4
King G5 played by Fabi and that's that's
even better according to machine then
Queen F4
interesting King G5 on the board
check and yeah now Queen F4 finishes the
game
he's done it Point F5 check
oh
big result here is go cash
with only seconds
you know you always think in these Queen
endings that you've got a chance Queen
A3 there's always a chance but five is
not even in real time trouble no he's
not uh can we no Queen E4 check and E7
does blunder the G3 Pawn or sacrifice it
yeah
it draws it's a blunder sorry Mira what
yeah just give a check on e4 and then do
pretty much anything E7 wins G4 wins
after check on e4 okay and
by the way just peeking ahead I had to
do it I looked at round eight I know
Miro was saying as we came on the show
the road ahead for the players but the
road ahead it for round eight features
foppy
Apple The Clash of the two two leaders
two leaders he did play E7 he did
sacrifice how about King H5 now guess
the valiation of King H5
plus 47 mating six yes oh made it in six
believe it or not yeah it looks like
black has quite a few checks left but
it's mating six white wins not later
than a few moves what would we think if
Fabi played the move King H5 and said I
announced mate in six
could we bring out the wand yes it's a
quick check fair play check uh King H5
why is it made in six mirror three
seconds oh he resigned um who cash
resigned
uh
well that's a great result for Fabi I
was holding my breath I just realized I
needed to take a breath King H5
uh wow uh first of all I want to say
what an enterprising night sacrifice
Knight takes D3 and the fact that it was
not just engine approved but you know
better for goo cash
that's that that's shocking the Fabi
played so well defended so well and then
started to outplay and the mirror just
jumping over to you it was this move uh
he should he should have played Queen C5
he played yeah yeah the moment he
all right well just uh we're gonna be
jumping to Zagreb where we're gonna have
Chris Christian will will talk about
this uh peace sacrifice right but before
that yeah I said let's just uh well how
close it was yeah right let's let's uh
mention how close it was not the game
itself I think we leave it to Christian
but would you cash win it it'd be
absolutely different tournament we would
have nepo as the sole lead right and
then Anand sharing second with gukesh
while now it's Fabi and nepo right good
cash and uh yeah who was it pushed a
little bit back right and then Vichy on
the clear third position and you were
about to show as king H7 yeah
please mirror right so well once again
it's not that easy to understand the
difference but yes King H7 would have
given black a serious advantage and only
then King shade so there is no Queen E5
or if you take on E5 it's just bad
because there is no Rook H6 check Motif
as in the game
and let's just uh
refresh ourselves and take a look at our
standings as yet again another very
event for round six even though there
was a lot of draws
it really impacted our standings
absolutely so the two leaders coming in
today still remain the lead Fabiano
caruana and Yani pomichi who will face
each other in the next round and the
Sheep by virtue of his draw he's in
clear second and then in clear fourth
Duda
Magnus and Richie a drawing but gukesh
losing is a loud Magnus and to catch up
what an exciting round I'm waiting for
us to go to Croatia so we can get a view
a front row seat view there with
Christian as he's getting set up this
move King H5 by the way uh Checkmate in
six did you see the check made in six
you know the answer
I did not either so but uh let's jump uh
to Zagreb I'm Christian
thanks guys well I have to say uh this
round was a round of details and you
pointed a great detail in that situation
mirror when of uh Gucci could have
simply played King to H7 and I have to
point out the fact that he played that
whole sequence of moves so quickly
including King to h8 but I was paying
close attention to the time at that
point he had a minute and 30 seconds on
his clock if he stops and thinks for at
least 10 seconds we know he's such a
great technician so he would have
understood those details he would have
played King to H7 and then he would have
given Fabi a run for his money maybe
even uh be better in that position and
perhaps uh take the full point so that
was a pivotal moment in uh that game and
uh for the standings as well because
right now Fabiano is in the first
position but another game that I was
having my eyes on was this one between
Constantine lupuscu and firujo and I met
Constantine at breakfast of course he's
not having the greatest ornament of his
life only scored one point up to that
point up to this game and uh he was sort
of dejected he was telling me that he's
just playing uh too slow and I told him
yeah this is crucial you have to stay at
least within a margin of uh at most two
minutes within your opponent I remember
yesterday's game against Nepal Nepal had
like 20 minutes lupulasco only had like
one minute towards the end so
the position can be even winning for you
if you're only down to your last minute
and your opponent has so much time to
think that's just simply not a practical
situation you want to find yourself in
so I told him hey stay within two three
minutes of your opponent maximum and
this is exactly what he did very very
well in this game against Ali Reza in
fact towards the end he was the one with
two minutes and 30 seconds and alireza
with only 30 seconds on the crowd and I
have to say he had a great opportunity
to potentially score the full point take
this um take this moment as an example
Queen to F3 and Ali Reza played the move
H4 now it's all about putting my
majority into motion as white I want to
play G4 for example if the pawn remains
on H5 I want to play G4 next move push
F5 as well if I manage to get the pawns
on F5 E5 perhaps E6 as well if I manage
to put the majority into motion this is
Game Over All She Wrote so this is
exactly why black plays the move H4 now
G4 which was by the way played in the
game and not the best move it's
obviously
um aimed at trying to go F5 but
unfortunately after G4 you take take and
now F5 is much more difficult to be a
played what he had to do is in fact
threaten the move F5 with a move Rook to
F2 and now I'm not 100 sure what he
missed you cannot defend against F5 with
your queen this is crucial because
you're dropping the D5 Pawn now what
about the Rook can you go Rook to F5 yes
you can do that but now I'm going to go
Queen to G4 finally I get access to this
Square G4 before that with the queen on
E6 and the C8 H3 diagonal uh still not
blocked by The Rook on F5 we would have
exchanged the Queens Queen hd48 the H
takes G4 and that's a completely
different story but after Queen to G4
next I'm going to pick up the pawn on H4
you cannot defend against that and then
G4 is coming once again this is
completely winning for white so after
Rook to F7 the only way to stop me from
playing F5 is with the move G6 but
unfortunately for your king after the
move G6 well I'm going to go Queen to G4
is one option G4 is another option and
this is a completely different story
because right now with the pawn on G6
that's going to be much easier to attack
I also have the H Pawn that I can use to
hook that pawn on G6 for example let's
say Rook to A6 you try to defend like
that at some point I'm going going to go
H4 H5 I'm going to force the trade of
these two pawns I'm going to force the
opening of your king and after that it's
all she wrote Because you simply cannot
stop my attack on the G and file so this
was a critical moment for lupuscu after
that unfortunately he didn't have any
extraordinary chances to take the full
point home but still a good sign for the
struggling a Romanian guys
quite an interesting game this was let's
take a look at the standings after this
seventh round we see Fabiano caruana and
Ian nepomyashi who will be battling in
the next round leading the pack with 10
points a piece
of Duda with 8 and Magnus and Richie and
gukesh with seven points and right now
we're going to go on a short break but
Anastasia actually caught with the
players take a look
[Music]
how does it feel to be here for branches
during Croatia it feels really good to
be to be back here always have a good
feeling coming to Zagreb and Croatia so
I'm good to go yeah Zagreb is one of my
favorite cities and I always feel very
comfortable here
um the everything about this tournament
is amazing like everything is
professional so I'm very happy to be
back
it's a fantastic feeling I've been in a
I've played in granchester in back in 21
it was all amazing so I'm very very
happy to be here again
uh this is my third year so now it's
becoming traditional and I'm every year
I'm looking forward to it it's one of my
favorite tournaments and the strongest
one as well uh with the toughest
opposition
to meet so I'm always always
being optimistic and I'm trying to to
make it to to be better than the last
year yeah it's uh it's always been my
dream to play in the grandchester and
it's my debut so I'm really looking
forward to it yeah everything in Zagreb
is perfect so far hopefully I'll have a
very good tournament as well
um
one of my favorite countries to to visit
and
probably one of my favorite events to
play
and yeah probably didn't believe so it's
not too
too much prep yeah not too much tension
just just up on
looking forward I'm very happy to be in
Zagreb again I enjoyed my visit two
years back
I mean two years back so it was very
very special because it was my
first tournament during the pandemic and
I could literally Escape here and I
spent a whole month here but this time
it's shorter but still very happy to
come back I have lots of friends I've
been catching up last few days and
looking forward to that and also
hopefully a good tournament yeah it
feels feels good it's been four years
since I've been here last year I played
in Poland and 2019 we were playing
classical chess
so it's going to be a bit different but
I'm also very motivated especially since
at the moment it's going well in the in
the franchise tour for me and so
hopefully I'll keep that up oh it feels
pretty nice this is actually my first
time
being in Sacramento overall and yeah
I've been to Croatia and even played
some just in Croatia but it was like
another lifetime
yeah it feels very interesting and I
think Croatia being you know part of
this former Yugoslavian countries I
think chess is very well regarded
still and I'm looking forward yeah it's
very nice I had played once before two
years ago exactly here I mean I was
staying here it's very hot for Western
in Zagreb but I sort of forgot about it
to be honest and now when I'm back it's
nice you know because like memory comes
back and um
yeah it was the last time for sure I
mean it was nice time
there so I hope this family will be even
better
[Music]
thank you it's time to fight for titles
the best juniors girls and Senior chess
players converge in the chess capital of
America St Louis Missouri for the U.S
junior girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shavalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why just as
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
foreign
[Music]
rapid and Blitz from Zagreb Croatia
after seven six rounds seven rounds
seven rounds a play what do we have we
have two call leaders Fabiano caruana
and Yani pomnishe in clear third
visionand and clear fourth yanduda and a
nice tie for fifth through seven with
Magnus Ritchie and gukash and round
eight coming up and what a mouthwatering
pairing we have in nepo versus badly
that's our key matchup to leaders facing
each other but we have other very
interesting matchups Carlton again
Studio very close in points exactly
all Indian Derby yeah I wonder if they
have already played each other I'm sure
they have I think that she's actually
been working with gurukasha especially
because of the Chennai Olympia firuja
against sarich and Robert against
lupolasco and in that Napa versus Fabi
match I'm gonna I'm very curious try to
guess in advance what you think their
head to head might be in Rapid yep I'm
gonna say five is in the lid Barbies in
the lead I was extremely wrong I
take the other side of the bed
wow uh I would have I would have maybe
been on your side on that one I didn't
see that coming 18 to 8 18 to 8 and 24
draws so these guys know each other very
well indeed they do Miro jump in did you
expect that result between the two uh
well not at all I would I would expect
Nepal to be leading but not by that kind
of margin of course
uh well I have something to say that
Fabi was known to be a weak player in
you know in shorter time controls right
I mean there was four or five years ago
yeah but by now it's obviously just a
meme right like Fabi weakened Blitz I
mean come on he was world number one at
some point right so yeah so maybe once
again we we shouldn't really rely on
this statistic too much uh through that
but uh we are expecting a huge Clash
because as you have been telling as the
player who leads in the rapid tends to
win these uh rapid and Blitz events I
mean unless Magnus decides he's going to
go plus 10 in the blitz uh having a lead
in the rapid is uh very very nice uh we
just wanted to mention that for me
watching Vichy on the white side of the
open Sicilians seems to be struggling
his game against sarich in his game uh
just now against Duda weren't that
particularly impressive uh he's not
getting the advantages with white that
he's known for Miro uh right even though
he beats are rich eventually right but
the the opening uh didn't really go his
way and now while he was he was
struggling obviously right well we see I
think experience what makes him you know
a good player now because even if the
opening doesn't go his way he knows kind
of
identifies the key points you know where
to Bluff a little bit where to uh go
fishing in the murky water and it works
it works so the only game he lost was
against Magnus but uh yeah there he was
just steam you know the steamrolled and
his intuition is probably the best out
of all the players because intuition
comes from experience absolutely and
when I watched Vichy growing up I
thought he was one of the greatest
talents I still believe that today by
the way one of the greatest talents I've
ever seen in my life and playing him you
know blindfold during the blitz during a
dinner
we just talk about the position and he
would just be conversing as if it was
right in front of him by the way for goo
cash as he's about to play this
legendary figure uh Vichy Anand on the
other side of the board think of go cash
17 years old uh from the time he was
growing up as a chess player he must
have always been looking up at Vision
not and now the guys on the other side
of the board and you're supposed to beat
him uh how do you do that when you're
playing your hero Mira right that's I
imagine it's very tough right because
even in terms of opening preparation
that's basically the guy who taught you
to play Chess at some point right Vision
mentioned in an interview that he was at
some point coaching those younger Indian
players specifically for the Olympian so
it's really really tough you know tough
task to do cash and I believe when Anand
was playing World Championship match one
of his first ones kukesh wasn't even
born yet
true let me bring you up but we also
have one more very principle do or even
though not on let's say not the leaders
leaders but Magnus against Duda Magnus
against dude it's always you know
somewhat heated up apps absolutely and
they are underway
yeah
Magnus on the white side of a Catalan
and by the way we have a French defense
against Fabi French
with a2a3 and that for me has always
been the Principal answer to Queen B6 I
I think the advanced French to France is
the way that white should go and then
with A3 C5 C4 and Knight A5 I love these
strategical struggles uh struggles I
wanted to say yeah Knight A5 and uh jump
in Miro uh A3 uh
an old page a classical approach and
what do the modern statistics tell us uh
right well you you know it's too early
to say because that many games so let me
update you Queen B6 A3 was played in
3849 games very good all right C4 the
most principal response Knight B to D2
and then it all goes about white being
or not being able to push B3 right so
Knight to A5 Bishop E2 Bishop D7
castles short and then once again you
have let me try to count it briefly 10
options for black wow so every sensible
move you can imagine has been and maybe
unsensible because Knight H6 was tried
h7h6 was tried and so on and so forth
it's a bit too easy to a too early to
tell pardon me so well white
statistically well scores more but not
you know not by huge margins 35 percent
white winds 24 black winds after Carson
short and we do have castles long on the
board yep Castle's long one of the main
moves let me scroll who the players are
it seems it was not played lately at
least by kind of big players right I can
see a game of mamid yarov back in 2003
yes so it must have been okay he was
already 2600
it is long ago it's like 20 years ago
castles I just wanted to say that in the
game between Vichy and gukesh by the way
we saw the fantasy variation yet again
F2 F3 has this become a popular option
again don't get it I don't get it uh I
always thought the fantasy variation was
easy for black to deal with because I
used to see in the advanced that's where
the most challenges are for black
exactly Knight D7 by the way Vichy
mixing up his approach Bishop E3 Bishop
B4 on the board Bishop to D3
it might be already in a new territory
here yeah certainly I'm not familiar
with this Miro jump in on this one
Bishop E3 Bishop D3 it you you want to
say it's a winner or French it's not
Bishop D3
we only have one game so that that's
very rare very perhaps already Knight D7
Bishop before the combination of those
two is not the most popular but still
you do have some games uh let me check
in fact yeah Knight D7 it's 11 games
only
wow there should be three Bishop B4 and
Bishop D3 only one game uh while
Grandmaster Bachmann has played against
very young
I don't know maybe didn't become a grand
master since Knight to E7 it's still
this game but uh yeah yeah only one game
no Theory and it's it looks unlikely it
will transpose to anything anything
familiar okay uh jumping to the game of
uh Duda and Magnus crossover let me get
it there yeah wow it's a catalog right
boy but they have zipped their way to
the current position and remember that
this was a somebody blundered the game
in like one move I have this impression
it was a game of Wesley so when Miro
said it's Carol and I'm looking at the
position I was like where is the bishop
on G2 that's right got traded uh yeah so
it was Wesley so versus uh Eon Duda
where uh Duda actually blundered in one
move and just uh lost the game Rook
takes C6 all Theory uh to this moment uh
Miro all right I'm trying to identify
where we are taking kind of the side
route because yeah Bishop C6 is not the
most popular and then after Bishop C6
you have Rook D1 intermediate much more
common than an immediate capture on C6
after which we have in the current
position we have how many like six games
only in one of them you'd be surprised
from 1978 Petrosian but wrong so to
speak wrong performance
and yeah
okay so that's it Rook D1 Queen A5 and
we transposed in fact now we have more
games well white could have played Rook
D1 first
okay and let's just check out the
lifetime the head-to-head matches oh
this was more expected yeah but I didn't
expect that many games that was 20 draws
54 games Justin rock hit 24 wins for
Magnus 10 losses not bad for Duda and 20
draws if you can put 10 losses you on
Magnus Carlson you can be proud of
yourself that is a quite remarkable
um I wanted to turn to the game of our
two tournament leaders for a moment
because uh uh I want to say that nepo
did something you you you're not
supposed to be able to do
he did play the move Rook to B1
and I think it's pretty obvious he wants
to play B3 and or B4 to try to blast
open on the queen side I remember ideas
of David bronstein was to play Knight to
B3 Knight takes B3 Bishop to A4 and you
almost forced to play Knight to D2 in
these positions as uh white but
um Fabi played H7 H6
which is okay I can't believe that
you're really afraid of the move Knight
to G5 and he almost invited
uh the move before which was played and
followed up with C4 so from White's
point of view he's saying look I want to
get at your king I want to blast open
the queen side and if I can play C5 and
Knight takes B3 I'm happy jump in please
since you just said that then why C5 why
not C takes D5 and actually open up the
C file
sorry after C4 after C4 the next move
instead of C5 and blocking the C file we
want to open up the queen side right why
not take on D5 next move all right uh so
let me give him a king B8 and or 97 yeah
four we have more Bishop A4 oh he did
okay one and we have C5 on the board but
instead
why not take why not take yes okay take
take
and we have the open C file
uh well yeah I guess you you do with
that you would have to play Bishop B2
Rook C1 well the business squares are
kind of pretty well covered King B8 I
guess it's not enough
it doesn't feel it um it's a pawn
sacrifice mural and uh
your fabby's saying
prove it okay so a few observations if
you allow me please uh first of all h7h6
not the most popular move it's a king B8
mostly played in this position and
perhaps you really could use uh the fact
that King is no longer on the C file
right after age six uh it's not a deep
analysis I'm just seeing the machine
machine turns to favor white a lot and
specifically for this reason B3 or B4
after B4 blacks practically forced to
take on poisson C4 Bishop A4 all good
capturing on D5 was very interesting I'm
not sure if beta or worse than C5 but a
very interesting move however you really
had to find Knight takes B3 wow which is
somewhat computer-ish because yeah you
sacrifice a piece and you do not win it
immediately if Knight takes the only way
to get the material back is to go Bishop
D3 threatening Bishop C2 and that's not
obvious at all right and then look and
then if the bishop takes
it's sort of the same pattern you go
here and then you go Bishop D2 and
Bishop D1 so you win the piece back in
few moves I I want my opponent checked
right so that's why and after C5 in fact
the white seal still seems to be better
after all those moves Bishop C3 Knight
E2 C6 and some games popped up
interestingly
my guess that some games scene Knight E7
all that on the queen side and then H6
later on because it was kind of a
transposition and finally Queen C1 is
the First Independent move which engine
doesn't improve uh Queen C1 funnily
enough I understand because he does want
to play Bishop to D1 what was the engine
Improvement a knight E1 to D3 somewhere
Knight E1 Knight E1 wow right and then
say in case of King B8 Knight jumps to
dd3 and we're threatening Knight B2 well
yeah Knight B2 is a sneaky threat to try
sneaky right wow okay Queen C1 and the
engine evaluation is nothing bad for
white white slightly better point three
in white favor and black black doesn't
have anything decisive so to speak plays
Bishop E7 or B6 in terms of change in
the position a little bit B6 is of
course more more tempting and then
according to machine white has to take
Knight takes and the queen to C3 once
again it's not an easy move to play
going to C3 if black captures he is lost
once again don't ask me all right yes
he's lost because you allow Knight to D4
apparently and at least here I can see
why the king would be better off on B8
because now of course you cannot take C5
because Rook C1 is gonna happen exactly
right here we are after Queen C1 and
yeah everything is ahead of us let's
remind our viewers how nepo uh got to
the stage I mean he started with a big
fat zero and it could have gotten worse
that day one was terrible she got it out
of his system he did all the mistakes
early yes and then look at the Finish
four wins in a row and those are two big
points for each of those victories and
that propelled him to a tie for First
with Bobby let's jump to the game of
blue cash for a moment because he's not
intimidated uh he's playing this uh
fantasy variation with Bishop D3 the
players are literally on their own this
is not a common position at all if you
thought it came from a winner where
you're excused because Bishop takes C3 B
takes C3 97 Knight E2 on the board and
for the moment strange structure already
yeah but I'm I'm kind of happy with
white it's it's not just the extra Pawn
which you know it really is yeah it's
enough for me it's the two Bishops two
Bishops look fantastic open position the
fact that I have a DeForest Pawn Yeah I
have a D4 Square I'm not saying I want
two pieces to occupy D4 I want both the
bishop as well as the Knight I do want
to play C4 I do want to play castles I
got the two Bishops and vichy's gonna
have to prove
his position Miro I think gukesh is
going to be happy with the outcome of
the opening at least so far right you
are yasa so C5 apparently and it was a
new move bertie's not the good one
because then later on it's almost
automatic that you have to capture right
dc5 computer doesn't take on C3 but then
it's not clear what four you have
sacrificed the pawn right right so you
capture you go 97 92 castles and here uh
castles for white is the most tempting
but arguably the stronger move is Knight
to C1 being ready to protect the pawn on
C5 right exactly and then it's not the
engine move but I'm thinking what
happens if Queen a5's played Knight b3s
of the engine gives away this one and
goes Queen D2 and claims this to be a
very very advantageous end game for for
white plus one yeah it feels very very
nice indeed like that move Knight C1 uh
very much uh there so we'll keep an eye
on that one and I want to jump to the
Magnus Carlson game again because uh
Duda should be familiar with this
position after his uh game with Wesley
so uh Rook C1 again are they still
following the precepts of theory
uh mirror yeah yeah that's what I'm
trying to figure out it's interesting
after Queen A5 yes after Queen A5 uh
well if you're not very experienced
using the database you might see that a
lot of strange and familiar names but in
fact it turns out it's only like eight
games or so but these are played in
correspondence chess and you know what I
mean if something is played this
correspondence chat that means it is
quote unquote correct variation right
right so after Queen A5 there is a funny
alternative to Bishop G5 which is Bishop
to H6
which is Bishop to H6 and then you would
think Castle is impossible because
Bishop G7 and then a check I check a
check and but yeah but black has Bishop
F2 contech and this is this is roughly
equal
um I wonder if black is the one to be
preferred after Bishop G5 Bishop B7
castles uh there is one game left in the
database that's not a correspondence
game
and computer favors white slightly I
have to say Castle's short it goes
Knight to E4 and trade here trade here
94 Bishop E7 claims that Bishop in this
particular case is much stronger than
the Knight almost plus one Pawn
Advantage for one
intriguing indeed oh wow uh going just
around the the tournament Hall we have
uh the I want to say Bobby Fischer
attack it's actually the king's Indian
uh attack uh Kings but Bobby Fischer won
a number of games
American players kind of adopted it and
gave it uh to Bobby you put your Pawn on
E5 you put your Pawn on H4 and I think
it was Archer Yusuf who first said to me
uh why do they call it an attack it's
not an attack there's no attack
on the black king and you see a lot of
players willingly going to this position
because they want to challenge white to
prove themselves for me you know Bobby's
Bobby you know we were all so impressed
by his victories we we thought that
Knight H2 and Knight G5 and the attack
plays itself uh marrow how does it how
would today's modern engines assess such
a position as this one right if we're
speaking of numbers there is such
numbers zero zero and that's that's I'm
afraid that's the evaluation zero what I
wanted to do what I wanted to point out
that I think Fisher times they were
playing this position with the pawn
being on C2 yes right so the one would
be on C2 and already by that time the
Knight would be jumping to G4 to be
sacrificed on F6 and so on right but
well nowadays modern players they are
not interested in getting checkmated
that much so and hence this maneuver an
interesting maneuver Rook goes all the
way to C8
and then Queen d8 so Queen will help to
guard the black king right and Rooks
will support the advance of those pawns
says it's equal still have one game in
the database so it all happened
that's it for now that's it for now uh
let's jump to uh right oh yeah napo's
game uh
looks like he's doing even better than
last time we looked but he gave did that
move Bishop didn't that move catch you
as quite a striking move oh she's a pawn
Grabber
he wants to win his Pawn back but uh you
you kind of think to yourself the night
on A5 is not going anywhere so sure but
that Bishop on C3
looks like a big pond we have a C5 D4 E5
so black squares are controlled with our
Pawn so United I'm not unhappy about
giving it up okay uh intriguing takes
takes Bishop uh at first blush uh it
wouldn't be appear to me that Fabi is a
happy camper because he's got this light
squared Bishop doing something uh it is
looking pretty but is it doing enough
another question is if we take back the
pawn say I just takes me three with the
Knights I understand I I I get this
imbalance of two nights versus two
Bishops and in a closed position in
close positions the knights can prance
uh you like Knight takes B3 okay yes but
Yan likes rookie 3 because that's what
he just played yeah I'm likes Rook E3 uh
with F5 on the board I apologize Rook E3
so the king size kind of closed of
course a black can play G5 F4 G4 but
it's going to be very hard for him to
open uh up the position I like nepo's
position by the way I prefer uh Mira
what do you have for us I have one
single move being made in magnus's game
but happens to be a very bad move so
Duda played H7 H6 attacking the bishop
or saw he thought because after Knight
E4 there is such thing called pin on the
H file you still cannot capture this
bishop and pretty much white gets
exactly the same position as we were
discussing which was already better for
white but black is not castled yet so
you really have to do something like
that and end up with
yas's favorite Pawn structure no it
might have six you know and then you're
suffering it's just something you would
prefer to trade the Queens right I mean
if at least Rook end game but that's the
problem you're not on time Rook D6 you
lose the pawn you lose the game so in
all this already depressing variation
you have to capture with the pawn and
computer has it as plus two for white
with material being equal so that's a
huge mistake h7h6 which is extraordinary
for me because this will be a second
time that Duda goes down to defeat from
virtually the same position one time he
lost to Wesley so right away and h7h6
he's mixing up his lines uh what's going
on and 94 has just played as you just
described it it's it's crushing I was
gonna say but Magnus has to find 94 then
I realized his Magnus okay he will find
it uh no that that's the type of move
that really plays itself you you you the
the H Pawn is pinned the night is oh and
dude I'm in real trouble my goodness uh
really a huge turnaround and you know if
I may uh there is there is a such thing
as kind of float logic I mean when you
play H7 H6 what do you expect Magnus to
do
it's not going to take on F6 no move
away let you jump Knight D5 so you
should be looking for some tactical ways
for white right and then you immediately
identify that there is 94 and it's and
it's bad
uh it was funny because just that
variation that you were showing with
Rook takes Bond takes uh
um what was it night takes Bishop takes
I would never want to trade Queens even
though you were saying that the Rook
ending is is favorable I'm looking at
the position after Queen B4 and I'm
saying dude you got your kingdom honey
that looks awful like Ah that's just
like something is really really gone you
know off the rails completely wrong for
for black if you were Castle I still
wouldn't like Black's position I'm
castled I think it's over so Magnus uh
looking good here a game we haven't
really looked at the let's jump to that
game and that's Ali Reza versus uh
Yvonne sarage not even sure it did come
from a king's Indian so Yvonne sarich
even though he's up against the most
formidable opponents in the world he is
true to his King's Indian roots and uh
let's see how the players got to their
current position two Bishops for white
space
I was surprised when feroza just took on
H4
and separated the pawns G4 looks maybe
he didn't like something uh specific
like G5 probably it had to be that he he
wasn't prepared to give up the E5 Square
um
H4 tags Queen takes Rook F1
Knight B6 92
and I think we've caught up with the
players
uh your quick uh knee jerk I don't like
this must move forward after Knight G5
uh my two pawns are hanging H3 and E4
well spotted defend both yeah uh I can
block
your attack on the E4 Pawn with the move
Knight F4 but okay I'm just trying to
use a different one now yeah I'm trying
to get my head around what I'm going to
do uh on this case so maybe I can take
on he took on G6 first right it's a
previous and then Knight F4 and then
neither something also potentially uh is
possible with fobby's game I'm gonna
toss it over to you marrow uh because uh
this is deciding first place in the
tournament uh right you are and let me
go a little bit back because you had a
wonderful discussion how Black's Bishop
is active and everything right it looks
good yeah that was the moment where
White had more than plus two believe it
or not and yeah it all goes back to the
fact that F7 F6 and later on F6 F5 was
just a waste of time so he would he was
better off playing B6 or simple Bishop
E7 so here White had even a stronger
move would have been Queen C3
instead of rookie three yeah if you go
Bishop E4 then just Knight B3 apparently
White's initiative Queen side is too
strong
uh right rookie 3 was fine Bishop back
to A6 Rook C3 and this may be somewhere
around this moment nepo kind of slow
played it a little bit Bishop B7 Knight
takes uh Knight C4 relatively okay Rook
to B1 G5 and this G5 once again I mean
you are clearly behind it's easy to
criticize when I see the engine in
evaluation first of all it's important
me but it's very often like when you're
behind you really want to find a moment
to you know to come up with a counter
play G5 and usually
regrettably so it's a wrong move and and
this is pretty much the case so G5 black
will never be on time
Knight F to D2 G4 Knight takes Pawn
takes and yeah well that there is a
funny move computer recommends which is
issue and when you take it takes and
when you take it just says you know what
you're not even Rush yes yeah just go C6
I take the B3 pawn and I'm completely
winning yeah because over here uh Jan
decided to sacrifice an exchange instead
which is also very very strong and much
more understandable from humans than
boys I would argue so now if Bishop
takes Queen takes
this feeling that Bishop on E7 it is
there but it doesn't do much right and
once again after Rook B5 white is not in
Rush he simply plays this position
Bishop to E2 move the queen away go
Bishop C4
looks green for Fabi if you ask
yeah in exchange for Pawn but really
massive phone center right yeah and the
light squares as well the bishop on E7
is not helping Black's cause
yeah but he was also looking afar right
like he has that uh glazed look like
he's looking in the Horizon uh remember
playing a lot of players who had that
look on their calculated if I win this
this will be fifth scenario
and uh Miro uh news of the madness yeah
news of the Magnus and now at least I
probably have to take back some
criticism on Duda because I just figured
out yes indeed the engine is Right white
is close to winning and everything but
if you're a human chess player don't you
rely on this move Queen D2 which wins
for black I'm not showing you this right
wins for black in every single line
except except for Bishop G5 back and
this is the move you easily missing
easily Bishop to G5 back Pawn cannot
take same reason with a check Rook is
now protected if Knight takes no longer
white king is in danger and you can go
to C8 and grab the Rook if you would
have done so immediately however like go
here
skin to D7 capture Rook guards d8 so
there is no Rook d8 right and if you
take this guy it's a check
followed by another check followed by
one more check and that's the last check
on F5
so
understandably and and he did play it
Queen D2 so now it's a key moment
because if Carson doesn't fight Bishop
G5 he's lost he finds it he wins he
finds it is it's what we call a 50 50
right well I think reading their body
language Duda knows he's lost because he
does not look happy so he sees Bishop G5
I'm sure Magnus has spotted it too at
least you can read from duda's face that
okay what's the over and under of for
Magnus finding Bishop G5 I think you're
from Las Vegas so I mean you got to be
familiar with the over and unders I mean
Magnus 100 100 wow
and he's reaching for his Bishop by the
way
of course
and instantly Knight takes G5 I mean
Duda had seen
this problem uh from afar so this
opening is just unlucky for Duda it
would appear that way I mean he's just
uh he's giving away a lot of points uh
with this opening uh you know it's funny
uh it is it really resigns though I mean
I understand I'm an exchange down but
after this move Queen takes E2 I have
one upon unless Miro it's the queen B4
check move that is that the Killer Queen
before King F6 right
an F4 check okay
should be fine uh Queen so let's say I
go King F6 and you go Queen F4 check and
I go King G6 no king king G2 so somehow
my king safety right
um I do have a pawn you have E5 move but
then Queen E3 the end game should be
good because your A7 B7 Panzer weak and
your Knights too far away to protect
them so
wow I
is but is this so bad Miro is this so
bad uh you guys are brilliant you just
identified the only line which leads to
White's Advantage okay and it is a
decisive Advantage it's decisive yeah
even even if he finds Queen check
followed by Queen check by King G2 which
is he probably will wow right but
so but once again my apologies to do
that right I mean the guy seen all that
missed Bishop G5 and even after Bishop
G5 it appeared to be unclear unless for
this pendulum checks and King G2
well I think Queen before Queen effort
is kind of forced because you don't want
to allow those checks with the Knight
and queen of course and you have to
protect the F3 square and you do it with
the King on G2 all right in the moment
the Knight is pinned on G5 so maybe
Magnus feels like he doesn't have to
rush the queen moves there's no Knight
F3 coming fair but I do have a pipette
maybe on the board
so like I mean you Rook you you'd kind
of like to get your Rook back into the
game whether you go to B8 or you go to
A8 uh you'd like to get but there is
unfortunately for Magnus uh a prepaid
that he has to deal with and that was
why he did play the move Queen before by
the way
King F6 on the board we assume we just
have other checks here as well like
Queen C3 check and then then going
straight to E3
but no why am I doubting this is going
to find the absolute best move queen of
hurricane and uh let's just remind
ourselves as well as our viewers where
they stand in the standings uh
Magnus is sharing fifth at the moment uh
kind of a repeat of his polish
so rapid is a warm-up for him yeah yeah
and then he gets into the blitz but he's
lurking seven he's giving the field a
three-point lead that wasn't enough for
Duda in Poland and he's playing Dura so
who is a little bit higher than him
right now so overtake him potentially
yes
and uh let's jump back to our Marquee
matchup as our two tournament leaders
are matched in this and nepo back at the
board I like how nepo just walks around
in the rapid cave
there's so much time on the clock when
we left it we left it at this at this
point nepo had uh sacrificed in exchange
for a pawn and he's got these light
squares so he can always play this move
Bishop
C4 which I think is just going to force
uh black to give back the exchange and
NASA you were about to say something
I Knight A5 right works
immediately Knight A5 because excuse me
I have Knight C6 that's nice right Rook
takes D4 that is a very pretty move you
don't get involved in any discussions
about
Rook takes B7 but you just take
advantage of the pin Knight C6 check and
once the light continues there's there's
Queen C6 Queen will be up in exchange at
the end Queen C6 Queen takes c66 Rook D1
check
yep
Bishop takes D1 yeah
and then where this yeah this one
there's no doubts in my mind that this
is a winning uh ending for white so we
can't take so Knight A5 uh
yeah it looks refreshing though King A8
and we can take on B7 why Rook B7 and
now if Rook takes B7 then Rook takes D4
sort of works not not like really works
but black captures back on D4 Queen
takes B7 Queen d8 Bishop d8 Knight B7
King B7 and there is no guarantee this
is winning it's supposed to call it
Bishops right computer has it that's
plus one but you know aren't aren't
aren't those pawns falling in in a row
in the final position Bishop c45 E5 is
falling as well right so it's Bishop C4
it goes F4
when you capture it goes King C6 even
so there is no guarantee I would argue
and especially yes if instead of Knight
A5 and I think that's what what Nepal
does he stopped he does a good job
nowadays right stopping in a critical
position because it it's somewhat
computer-ish or you know from exercises
of Mark boretsky but if you ask yourself
like what piece is not participating
it's this guy only two right and then
there is G3 right so Bishop F1 and
Bishop G2 and this happens to be like
overwhelming for black almost plus three
nice uh this whole variation with Knight
A5 and Rook takes D4 uh reminds me of a
wonderful story of Ben Larson and he was
playing against uh Grandmaster from
Sweden and bent was in this bad position
like Fabi and he went for this uh crazy
hold on it wasn't 1960 King h a king A8
Rook takes B B7 Rook takes Queen takes
Knight takes Rook takes just that
variation that we were getting Without a
Queen B7 immediately Rook D4 yeah here
Rook D4 and then it was Queen D4 and uh
bent lost
this uh ending and he said to his
opponent well why did you go into this
Bishops of opposite color position
and the answer was but young man
don't you understand in such positions I
can never lose
the color ending
um this is nice I love that move G3 what
you were suggesting though it's not
really nepo style though right yeah
definitely likes to uh check me
Checkmate but uh G3
basically says your turn what are you
going to do uh but Jason is hard to make
because in this position it feels like
white should already have a winning
combination and you're looking for these
Knight a5s and Bishop C4 kind of moves
what's the clock Times by the way of the
players uh nepo has 17 minutes and 5 B13
or sorry that's wrong
or nipples down to 12 minutes 12 and a
half he's been thinking for a while on
the last move and Fabi has 11 minutes
and taking his time this is a very
critical moment
if he comes up with G3 you just got to
tip your head and say really well done
let's jump to the game of Richie for a
moment because Richie looks like he's
doing pretty darn good this was the
Bobby Fischer attack if you will uh and
if you said that this game came out of a
French I wouldn't believe you
Queen A2 last move uh no I'm not
interested in giving up the A3 Pawn uh
black pieces on the queen cider so they
look pretty but they're so limited well
one guy looks pretty you know you put
this guy on B5 that would look pretty
but the one guy on B3 is Not Enough by
the way I mean I understand defending
the pawn but
that's a move I would rather have
resisted I mean I would be much more
attracted to Queen C2 and Knight G5 like
Queen C2 if you want to take a pawn and
I would play Knight G5 and I would be
laughing I would say what are your
pieces doing on the
Queen side I'm just going to Checkmate
you on the king side with Queen C2 and
uh
H5 Queen A2 I don't know why this attack
still seems a bit slow so why give that
counter play and give up E3 Pawn so you
like the move Queen A2 because it can
still go Knight G5 next move in H5 and
then come back Quincy two okay break the
tie first Miro I'm I'm advocating Pawn
sacrifices uh showing my true nature
yes I mean for people who know you might
think you're kidnapped Queen to C2 I've
is a decent move which keeps the
advantage but Queen A2 is simply and
better what I want to point out that a
few minutes
was the one to kill his own content play
entirely I don't know for what reason
because here well computer has it has
been better for black
uh so perhaps not so much of an attack
going on and just plays a move like
Bishop to C6 or Rook B8 so nothing fancy
and after C4 D4 all this sequence takes
takes Queen f8 could it possibly be that
localeska was hoping to capture this
spawn and missed Queen A2 or queen B2
right because now if you look at it
black needs a lot a lot of time to
create a second thread right you have to
get this Knight over here on B5 right so
it's like three four moves and give
white three four moves in this position
you know what's going to happen yeah
right
and by the way he did play uh after
Queen A2 Rook C7 uh Rook C7 is a move as
you said it's preparing Knight C8 to A7
to B5 H5 on the board and I just see
this as checkmating attack I I I don't
see Black's counter play uh on the queen
side I think I wanted to go back to
on the screen I think okay also uh he
defended his King there's no counter
play and now he's just trying to find a
way to Checkmate Blocks game okay
because he did find all of those moves
including up to King G2 E5 Queen E3
let's trade Queens no thank you check
and how should the Magnus continue
I'm not sure
Magnus will find it okay I like the move
uh Rook E8 by the way rookie eight Queen
F3 check and Rook E7 nice that looks
really really nice somehow the black
king is not comfy I wanted to go to the
game of nepo because I think
I think nepo's playing a gorgeous game
hey check this out he did play the move
G3 and after King A8 just bishop and
queen before let's not underestimate how
difficult it was to find G3 in that
position absolutely absolutely no no
seriously you just tip your hat and say
fantastic Fanta and and don't forget uh
Miro this is rapid chess I mean it's not
correspondence you know we would really
appreciate and it's not classical either
in Rapid chess these guys are playing
superbly well
please yeah right you are so well
fobby's lost couple of moves and
specifically this F4 is well one may
consider as beginning of an end right
desperate she takes Rook takes however
white still has to be precise it seems
is one of the lines I mean you'd be
you'd be laughing at it Queen D2 for now
we're protecting the pawn but we've
planted this one right Knight takes Rook
takes and there is a pain and then we've
seen it all we take on B7 you know and
it goes like this and right and one may
just look at the variation and say okay
why it's completely winning but if you
have to find moves like this it's no
easy man not at all yeah like group B7
and then if Queen takes pawn it takes
why it's still an exchange down but this
bishop on G2 just just kills the game
Monster right so the queen D2
the whole sequence starting with yeah
no that's that that's very very pretty
uh by the way the move Queen D2 isn't
like that clear to me so it's a backward
move with the attack in piece wouldn't
you want to play Bishop G2 why would
Bishop he played yeah Bishop
Bishop G2 is good enough because I have
this idea of C6 in mind yes C6 because
if you take on D5 and give up your best
piece that's not condensing right then
blood can come back and defend this
exactly
um how is it how is it gonna go uh
how will the variation continue from
here Mira off the bishop G2 oh after
Rook takes that for you it takes F4 and
what was your what was your guess yeah I
thought it was C6 I was going to try it
you know what we what's going to happen
after you play C6 you might be screened
on using the engine no that's a that's a
good move yes yeah that's the best move
after which white is winning well the
idea from
is that after C6 if you took on C6 with
the pawn I have this lovely move Knight
C5 and I'm threatening mate so Queen C8
is the only move and this is where you
capture the group
he takes he takes doesn't matter much
and then it's still not over you have to
go Queen to a four Queen A4
threatening Rook B7
threatening perhaps Rook B7 and queen A4
doesn't look like a blunder yes it does
I was like Bishop takes C4 takes C5 and
Rook C1 and obviously it's an easy move
to find very difficult now that's what
I'm saying like wow if you only study in
chess by looking at what engine suggests
so practice very misleading Fabiano's F4
was great because now it's difficult for
me to still yeah you retain the
advantage I mean if you if you've missed
Queen D2 as white and you you want to
play Bishop G2 why did you play G3 in
Bishop F1 if not to play Bishop to G2
but Queen D2 first of all that's an
awkward retreating move you you resist
playing the move you want to play Bishop
G2 Rook takes but here is where I I find
it intriguing that Ian has stopped
himself once more in a critical moment
uh as he's considering C6 does he have
an alternative to C6 mirror uh the
alternative uh the funny fact is that
alternative is still to go to D2 now
it's even harder because because you are
not even protecting the F4 Pawn anymore
but that is a Tempo though right yes the
point is if Rook just goes back to fa ah
white captures on H6 thank you that's
what I'm talking about renew your
membership in the pawn grubbers
Association
I don't know you you haven't renewed
your membership in a long time Miro I
haven't seen you capturing pawns for a
while
that's right yeah and if speaking of
grabbing material if you decide to cash
in and caption D5 you practically
practically all of your advantage is
gone it's still in one yeah it's better
for white or maybe no no longer better
but because the computer gives this line
Knight to A5 right and then say Rook D4
Queen takes Queen takes and the Knight
takes and Good Luck winning this one I
mean that's what it's one Pawn lot of
weaknesses and black is relieved
obviously he's no longer getting
checkmated
and he's done it
he is taken and queen takes D5 on the
board uh by the way back again yeah a
lot of Ebbs and flows and so many of
these games I'm looking at the game
between the two Indian gukesh and uh
Vichy and the last movement is not
looking good it's Grim actually yeah I
just saw
and this D4 is hanging and age six is
weak the last rank is weak yeah a lot of
advantages it just feels like
uh gukash is playing wonderfully well
here after Queen takes D4 how big is the
advantage mirror it looks big you want
what I'm gonna do queen takes D4 I
wanted to take a pawn uh H6 is also weak
no it takes D5 it's still much better
but okay let me tell you queen queen
gives you plus five in this then yeah
the H6 Pawn is is a really right and
it's the best move according to the
engine is a rook to C5
we do have Queen H4 the very best move
in the position and well according to
machine announce the position is
completely lost he was already in a tie
straight but G5 was really made it worse
yeah made it significantly worse
wow
okay and now with King G7 there is just
96 Jacks so H6 Pawn is gone
and then
all white pieces are coming towards the
black skin and it's over
and go cash will catch Anand because of
course seven points for good cash the
third place
that's incredible for the 17 year old
it's his first time playing the grunge
store
and he's doing very very well as a wild
card the organizers really have a hard
time in the grand chest tour because
you've got you know the biggest sharks
in the world of Chess and now you've got
to get a wild card and the problem is if
you get a wild card that loses all their
games you're like why you know you're
you're suffering uh gukesh proving that
he's a future tournament participant
absolutely uh H5 on the board
how do we
I think Anan is just
um hoping for a miracle here exactly
you're taking apart either King H2 King
F2 they open G file is very compelling
uh you want to bring a rook put your
Pawn on age six and
land with your Rook on the seventh rank
Rook G7 uh looks really good I want to
go back to Fabi for just a moment
because
we've seen as we've been describing it
Ebbs and flows we didn't see the move
Knight A5 we saw Queen B5
and King F2 by the way with just looking
at the game of nepo and Fabi Queen uh B5
we are threatening check on E8 Miro
right as well as Knight A5 and the
reason move to stop both and this is
Bishop to d8 Bishop to
d85 stops Knight A5 and yeah you can go
for Queen E8 right and you would be
winning if not for Rook F3 yeah that's
what computer says yeah three and yeah
how to how to finish black I want to
play C6 you want to play C6 and it says
thank you it captures and not much you
can do well
not Bishop d8 by the way yeah let's
figure out what A6 means a chain queen
d8 queen d8 yeah but now white is better
in the end game he can trade King G2
that's what computer says once again and
uh White's position is better because
extra Pawn extra Pawn
but he also doesn't have to exchange the
Queens right he could play Queen G6
maybe grab another Pawn yeah
six black girls Queen D5 and queen back
to D5 back to E8 back to d8 Steel traits
that's that's what so taking on H6 is
too risky
I think it's that Rook F3 and let's jump
over to Magnus against Duda as uh Magnus
is about to win and handshake by the way
it was rookie eight uh by Magnus uh uh
setting up
and now as uh his usual he's back to his
usual self of resetting the pieces for
the next game unlike the game where he
lost back-to-back games where he was
just kind of stunned yeah froze
he was just frozen there uh for Duda not
a very good outing uh very disappointing
I would say it's a very good start but
then second day didn't go so well in
today not good uh again let's jump to go
cash and Vichy for just a moment because
I think things have gone really really
South for uh Avicii Knight takes D5 Rook
C8 check on the board gets close to some
checkmates here yeah no the patterns are
are just showing themselves
Knight G6 oh nice the rook h8
and Bishop
H six is on should be over White's
agenda here
that she knows that uh things are really
really bad King h7o H7 played and now
Knight G6 is the only move to win
interestingly but it's the most tempting
move at the same time exactly uh that's
the problem with this kind of a winning
move it just it just you know
it's a natural I'm surprised it's the
only move because I see 95 queen of four
isn't that also uh let's check so 95
it's Rook to D5 and queen F4 H5 Pawn is
hanging okay yes once again the engine
does wonders protecting those kind of
positions but after Knight G6 it's it's
done exactly by the way the problem also
with 95 Rook D5 suddenly the bishop on
uncovers The Rook all right
I was like oops you know like and
suddenly you've got G8 and queen H6 mate
is no longer made but Knight G6 is just
I mean it's it hits all of the uh points
Knight f8 check is a fork rook h8 and
Bishop H6 is a Checkmate you can't take
on G6
is failing right now about to defeat his
own personal hero I bet you his heart is
exploding you know like like it's kind
of disbelieving and this she resigns
and for good cash I mean it it is a it's
a really bizarre feeling all my life I
wanted to meet Bobby Fischer and play
against Bobby Fischer never had that
opportunity Bobby stopped playing uh he
played one more match in 1992 and that
was it but I couldn't just only imagine
myself feeling like I played Bobby
Fischer I won against Bobby Fischer I
would just like stop how do you continue
living actually exactly I've achieved
you know Mount Olympus here two games
remaining uh over to you Mero Howard how
is uh Richie doing uh Rapport is playing
a masterpiece in my opinion you know
beautiful looks great
yeah like just pay attention to the last
couple of moves that were played yes
whenever you get a chance yeah he did by
the way end up giving away the A3 Pawn
after all he just got it in in a
different fashion queen f8 takes takes
rookie three a Rover
Knight H4
Rook G3 Queen h8 Knight F5 you're forced
to take because H6 is hanging right
uh takes E6
uh hello
oh he took I thought he would you would
end up having to play Rook C8 he took I
think there's some bishop e5s and your
queen is unhappy no way the queen just
gets traps oh uh so at the moment it's
an exchange but it could be a rook as
well uh takes uh looks fantastic for
Richie he's certainly winning this uh
yeah everything everything is going in
his way
um back to Naples
C6 giving up well sacrificing his extra
Pawn looks like so there was a queen
trade yes and we didn't see King 8 King
G2 instead we saw A4 why does the pawn
on A4 C6
I'm assuming we're going to take is it
Rook C8
no it's a knight C5 immediately
Knight E6 on the agenda
so Rook takes D4
how is it going to go 96 Nasi 96 Brooks
D5 maybe 98 he wants to win this Rook
ending
you have rookie eight
so I have to keep the pawn I can't I
can't give up the E Pawn
by the way we have Bishop H4 on the
board Bishop H4
Knight C5 Bishop H4
uh not sure I like that one Miro 96 96
Bishop Bishop H4
feels you better like it yes it's the
best move and it really keeps the
position equal right equal relatively
balanced okay so after Knight D6 he's
planning to take on F2 with the check
it's probably no no with the rook and
probably it's not that easy to realize
that the attack on black cane it's
already kind of already not happening
right and it's important for black to
has at to have at least some from of his
own right so two versus one here on the
king side and black uh sorry white king
is no longer that comfortable and yeah
it's a white starts playing some strange
looking moves like Rook D1 and you know
this is typical computer stuff right
like Rook to D1 says A5 is possible Miro
I don't understand Rook D1 but why not
Rook F1 why not Rook F1 because Rook A2
Rook A2 right and it turns out yeah the
king is safe surprisingly
and the bishop on H4 will probably still
be there to stop the e-pawn if you try
it say move the knights try to run by
the way we do have a result Richie won
against Constantine the
the nightmare uh continues I think there
was a masterpiece from Robert so there's
nothing he can do in your opponent's
place so well uh Fisher random the final
position kind of Fisher random except
for a night on B3 let's go back to a lot
of special facial expressions he's not
happy not at all as Rook takes F2 on the
board you know it's very strange I mean
there's something blind about this when
when we were capturing on F2 I thought
you had to play Bishop takes F2 to stop
Knight C7 and Checkmate except it wasn't
Checkmate there was no mate at all must
be so frustrating it looks so winning
and yet you can't find where is the win
right where is it uh Rook C1 I think
what's more shocking is that nepo's down
on time
he has less than two minutes and Fabi
has more than four minutes remarkable uh
Rook C1 uh why didn't we go Rook B6 if
Our intention is to play Rook take C6 on
our next turn why didn't we play Rook B6
or maybe Rook C2 and I could tell you
yeah you're right stuck on A5 good point
good point yeah my Rook is not uh any
great shakes right so far we have three
results and it was all white wins in all
three games whitewash Rook takes rookie
two Rook takes C6 check
nice save from wow
wow and Nepal is so happy yeah what
happened to my win streak it it sure
looked like he was on the win streak and
we have one game remaining and that game
is a rook ending between alireza and
Yvonne sarich three versus two
extra one but
but a very active kid very active black
king as well also
just Rook F5 maybe once the oh we don't
win the pawn back because you can always
go to K7 I guess
no I like your Rook F5 and if you go
Rook A7 I'm not interested I will go
back
and now I want to play King James I play
B4 then my king Waltz is towards the uh
bee Pawn so it does look like a draw uh
here Amir I just want to get your
editorial opinion about the nepo versus
fobby game because I I really have the
feeling that nepo
let a big one get away they're still
analyzing by the way they haven't left
yeah absolutely no he totally got Fabio
of the hook and especially um you know
somewhat disappointed that or I imagine
how nepo is disappointed he finds all
the all the kind of all the hard Bells
G3 G3 and so on and so on and then yeah
just the winning post he should have
literally waited one more movement not
to capture on D5 right yes that would be
it exactly exactly uh very eventful
rounds uh could be we have as you said
three wins with the white pieces thus
far we do expect to draw between uh
farusha and Ivan sarich he's keeping the
extra Pawn but it could have very easily
been four wins uh had nepo yeah and he
has uh just played this oh he did play
B4 I'm a little bit surprised A4 I'm a
little surprised that uh trying to put
my king in checkmate
believe it or not but now it's the only
move King C3 which he previously made
otherwise he would have been lost okay
seven
how Okay 7 B6
um what C6 and if you capture it's King
B2 yeah you're threatening mate that's a
that's Beauty yeah wait is that so the
idea is Rook A7 now
if I allow you King B2 am I just me I'm
not sure if you go Rook a seven King B2
right away then I'm going to go King A5
and King B6 but you start with this very
clever B6 so that in case you capture
now if I play B5 you have C5 this is
winning football it looks like a study
it's a study with V6 eight seconds for
search eight no he won B5 check which
provokes king A5 and maybe white is
winning white is winning entirely after
King A5 and C takes B6 and passan is
Checkmate in three that loses
King A5 wins oh no I'm definitely gonna
use the same game as a static universe
oh my goodness B6 would have been
oh wow
that would have been amazing
B6
what I'm speechless yeah what a move but
B5 King A5
so now uh does spiritual still need to
be careful or can he just go King B6 I
think he can just start I'm not losing
C5 right King B6 King B4 King takes C6
Rook F5
no I can't take on C6 yet
uh can we start with Rook a site yeah
just move the Rook away so that you want
to play Rook check right so after Rook a
three check oops uh we can see that
Yvonne sarich is in serious time trouble
as he he kind of knocked the Rope there
we do have a rook check
we've got king take C6 and we have a
rook check a table base just popped up
saying that it's winning forced win yes
and you get in one check and then we'd
capture
nice
so King takes King B6
and we've improved the position of our
Rook
King B6 and we've improved the position
of our Rook so that we're ready to play
c65.
but beautiful too that that was a very
nice maneuver of Rook H4 and Rook H5
it's like
you know precision
and the clock times are oh feroza has
five and a half minutes plenty of time
I wonder if he's he spotted B6
and then I bet you and then when Yvonne
touched the B phone it's like oh
no and then it went to B5 instead of V6
oh no
and uh through the magic of Television
let's see the boner here a remarkable
study like move B7 B6 Charles the game
you could have drawn the game no
missed it by one square yeah
and after B5 King A5 and we have the
current position King
A4 we expect C6 must have spotted it
because he didn't even consider anpassan
he won King A5 exactly
no I'm sure he he did spot it uh as C6
is on the board and I am expecting a
handshake here because there's not
really anything that uh you can do he oh
pardon me he did play B4 I thought C7 oh
this is winning too because we get a
queen and it's B Pawn not an A or C Pawn
so right C7 is even cleaner right even
cleaner oh yes
check King B3 and even I would have
traded Rooks myself and then played C7
but C7 just to show that you have end
game techniques exactly exactly good
enough
uh unfortunately for Evon this is
not been a good day he I think he lost
his opening round around seven and uh
this one as well
four wins for the white and it might
have been easily could have been five
uh Thrills and Spills as we were saying
uh Miro uh tell us about this uh round
well you know what if in the middle of a
round you would ask me a mirror what you
think will be the only game that
finishes in the draw I would have a hard
time guessing
so yeah a lot of a lot of events of
course and yeah kudos to Fabi whom
reminder I had picked
yeah but that was yeah that was a very
very tough game and let's uh jump over
to uh Zagreb uh after this very eventful
round eight
what an incredible round but I have to
say guys gookesh is absolutely
terrifying let's not forget the guy is
only 17 years of age and he's playing
such mature chess and let's take a look
at some of the details in some critical
games in today's round take a look at
this uh position from the game between
gookesh and visual just played the move
C4 he's trying to change the pawn
structure and this is going to be the
theme of uh my session right now after
C4 he played the move d4 unfortunately
after the move d4 Bishop to D2 Rook to
E5 and Rook 2 D5 this was a critical
move perhaps missed by Anand now white
is getting the upper hand in my opinion
because once you take on D5 I take with
the pawn and then the Knight has to move
you're losing the D4 Pawn not only that
but I'm also centralizing my queen and
that is crucial for this position
he had a great moment and a great
opportunity after the move C4
vishwanathan that is to play the move
Knight to E5 and in fact this would have
uh led to a much better position because
at the end of everything you're just
simply going to be a pawn up for example
you can take on D5 I'm going to take on
D3 very important the fact that I'm
exchanging the knights and now we will
have opposite color Bishops but it is my
Bishop who has much better squares for
example I have the square B5 potentially
for my Bishop which is going to be a
defensive against your uh the approach
of your d-pawn I'm controlling the D7
Square not only that but unfortunately
for white in this position the d-pawn
most likely is not going to survive now
there are still great chances for white
uh due to the fact that we have opposite
color Bishops to potentially get a draw
in this position but it is only black
that has any chances for a victory so
this was a critical moment no our none
not played and unfortunately missed it
and you saw what happened Gucci has just
took advantage of his opponent's
mistakes and executed a perfect attack
absolutely terrifying only 17 years of
age incredible incredible uh junior and
let's take a look at another critical
moment I want to draw this game between
Ali Reza and Ivan sarich that we just
saw finish
and once again I want to focus on the
change of structures because I think
it's a critical critical idea that
um players of all ages have to grasp and
of all levels have to grasp let's take a
look at this position Knight to C5 Rook
to D1 Queen to E7 G3 H5 you're trying to
stop me from expanding with the black
pieces on the king side with G4 and that
is exactly what white is trying to do
expand on the king side and put pressure
on uh black this move H4 and it visually
it makes a lot of sense because after a
G4 you're thinking oh hey I'm going to
go G5 and I'm going to force you to
either take on G5 or go F5 but after F5
Knight f a F4 I have great control as
black over the dark squares and
strategically this means that I have a
great position right now I'm going to be
able to put either the Knight or an E5
perhaps even the bishop on E5 I have
great control over the dark squares but
what both players have missed it it's an
Intermezzo in this position and that is
the move E5 it's upon sacrifice but upon
sacrifice for such a great reason and
that is to um not allow you to take full
control over the dark Source once again
a strategical reason behind this Pawn
sacrifice and a very typical corn
sacrifice in this type of structures by
the way you take on uh E5 I go F5 you
put the Knight on F4 and right now sure
I'm going to be a pawn down but I'm
going to go Knight to E4 blockade in the
center I'm going to have this beautiful
night on e4 uh that's going to control
the whole position potentially land on
D6 potentially support the expansion on
the queen side with the move C5 I have
so many strategical and tactical ideas
in this position which gives me as wide
almost a decisive advantage on the
contrary you don't have any sort of
ways to make your extra Pawn felt in the
position as black so this would have led
to a great position for white for Ali
Reza we've seen what ensued after it was
actually just a
very very equal end game with the Rook
on E7 the pawns were equal but
unfortunately as you guys have mentioned
Ivan Savage is just simply not having a
great day at the office and alireza took
the full point home
intriguing games guys let's take a look
at the standings after around eight we
saw that incredible clash between the
two leaders that ended in a draw I have
to say that was a missed opportunity for
janapo miyashi because he was better out
of the opening and he could have taken
the full two points home 11 points for
Fabiano and young Magnus is getting
close Richie and Evan as well as gukesh
on nine points type for the third
position definitely vishwanathan is not
happy with the results he's had he's
having in today's rounds guys it's just
an incredible uh day of Rapid final game
of Rapid coming up shortly but before
that we will go on a short break and
Anastasia once again caught up with the
players take a look
[Music]
thank you
a young welcome back to Croatia you were
here in 2021 what kind of memories do
you have from that times
um yeah I think it was mostly good
memories I mean my tournament was
so so I finished a short fourth I think
for fifth video
if memory serves well but um I mean in
that very tournament I want two games I
mean beats games against Kasparov which
was of course A very huge thing for me
back then and uh yeah I mean you know I
played good games about games but in
general I was very like happy
with my performance here in the group so
yeah I'm looking forward you know
repeating it yeah I mean but again but
gaining better uh you know I'm crazy
yeah that's important yes and actually
now that the last time I saw you was in
Poland and this dramatic last round you
know when you played against Magnus and
like I was just wondering how did you
feel after that event and let's see what
happened after did you still analyze
this game or you just decided to forget
about it and just enjoy the second place
like what were your feelings right after
that grandchester
yeah I was quite unhappy to be honest
back then because usually you know when
you are a professional chess player that
is usually about negative like feedback
because when you win you win because you
have yourself at one euros and
especially when you feel you could you
know do better
and or made some you know
um unfortunate errors then
um yeah it can get very negative and in
my case it was like purely I mean second
place didn't make me happy dog because I
was like leading in most of the
tournaments
but um yeah but subjectively saying I
guess uh it was quite good performance
by by me and I'm looking to repeat it
yeah yeah I mean just really played
really well in Rapid and Blitz in Poland
and everybody noticed that you play
normally really good in uh in these
events in Poland but grantchester you
know it's it's happening in different
places do you think it kind of it has
some impact on chess players if you play
in different countries I mean does it
matter that much where you play or it's
not that's important
yeah I would say it's not so important
yeah but somehow it's rude and important
thing also I
did play very well in two last years so
yeah perhaps there is something you need
I'm not quite sure unfortunately you
know there are not so many great
tournaments in Poland
but but still I mean there are you know
new strong ones
I guess you know trustbox is like in
each place like looks like the same so I
guess it's um
in the end of the day doesn't really
matter yeah
um and also like speaking about Poland
do you feel that chess is like booming
right now in Poland and um like what's
happening right now do you feel the
difference last years before Broadway
after covet yeah I think a couple of
years ago he was like hi uh when in
pandemia times when there was also
Queen's Gambit series and right now I
think I mean I feel rather I kind of
stopped but um but still of course you
know there are many people like
following trust and playing chess so
you know I'm mostly focused on my own
career and don't really
what's going on let's say but um yeah
but I mean just I guess just has never
been as popular yeah yeah for sure it
was always popular and actually it's
really hard not to focus only on your
games and not on the audience because I
remember they were even saying something
in Polish language
like this before the last round I mean
it was really impressive uh yes and like
speaking about your career what are your
big goals what goals do you have for
this year
um well I have two guns uh
first and foremost I guess it's uh to
play well in the World Cup I don't
really see myself winning it again but
you never know I mean two years ago I
was actually feeling terribly in Sochi
but somehow one in the end so and you
never know and secondly to do a
here I mean going to store series
overall and
yeah I think these two things are like
kind of the most important yeah that's
great and all the best of luck for you
in achieving all those goals thank you
[Music]
it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shabalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
it's your move
the uni premiere of Chess plays the muni
through July 11th sponsored by St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame for ticketsmuni.org
foreign
Louis chess club is the Premier chess
facility in the United States and is
among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
two thousand chess lectures for anyone
to enjoy become a member and enjoy perks
such as free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also played to an award-winning
shop dedicated to chess merchandise All
Occasion gifts and plenty more at Q
Boutique you can shop both in store and
online for chess merchandise autograph
Collectibles chess campus souvenirs and
much much more from quirky greeting
cards to luxury chess sets there is
something for everyone at Q Boutique and
all purchases go right to benefiting new
exhibitions and programs at the World
Chess Hall of Fame dedicated to
exploring chess and its immense impact
on art and culture located on the first
floor of the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy a shopping experience like no
other and become everyone's favorite
Gift Giver if you can shop in store make
sure to check out Q boutiquestl.com for
a wide variety of gifts for everyone to
enjoy
foreign
[Music]
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85 000
students in both in school and after
school programs we created the select
chess training program in the junior
select chess training program in order
to elevate the skill level in students
across the St Louis area these students
receive professional training from Grand
Master varusha nicobian other programs
include chess cops a partnership with
the St Louis Police Department looking
to improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 2 250 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chest
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the super United rapid
and Blitz Croatia event after eight
rounds we've got quite a score
scoreboard we have two co-leaders
Fabiano caruan and janipamishi who have
extended their lead by one point so now
two points behind are four players
Magnus Carlson Richard Rapport
christianan and kukesh well great rounds
coming up as we uh have the final of the
Rapids uh yes final round today
lupulasco against Carlson mamas will try
to score another win absolutely Ivan
sarich playing Richard report Fabiano
caruana playing ferrugia that could be a
very crucial game as we get ready for
the blitz but please continue and
probably our key matchup are not against
Nepal omniche and look at the one right
behind that one too
yeah as a young Gustav uh
so lots of uh exciting games ahead but
as we get ready for the games
my bad I forgot to tell you about the
latest and greatest special from Q
Boutique here it is it is an engraved
Walnut wooden board it's a stunning
board making the perfect gift for
someone including yourself the board is
crafted from Walnut measuring 21 inches
by 21 inches with two and a quarter inch
squares and has unique rounded Corners
displays the laser logos of the World
Chess Hall of Fame on the H1 and A8
squares and the St Louis chess club on
the A1 and H6 squares and trust me when
I say these are very beautiful board and
you'll love playing on them so go to Q
Boutique for all your chest chopping
needs and with that we get ready for
round nine Miro it's been in a very
exciting day today and I'm looking
forward to an exciting ninth and final
rapid chest round while indeed diasa and
I'm constantly reminding myself not to
declare the winner of the rapid portion
that we know for tournament right let's
not forget there will be 18 more games
18 more points distributed in each round
right uh well but these two guys Fabi
and NEPA they really like their lead
going to the last round right two full
points so basically it's between this
two who's going to win the rapid portion
and yeah other guys also improving like
Magnus was in the Striking Distance now
yep right anything can happen for sure
and the number of decisive games has
been pretty remarkable uh as here we
have it 24 out of 40 60 percent it's not
bad for these guys oh very very very
nice uh I tell you and a lot of the
draws have been some of the most
exciting uh that's always the case
typically yeah
a game so I'm loving these rapid and
Blitz and a big shout out to our
sponsors uh the super United uh as well
as the St Louis chess club
and I wanted to say the the full of life
Foundation from Croatia uh Thank You for
Your sponsorship and for the tournament
it's really really been a great event
and from Anastasia's report on the
social media sites you can really see
the audience enjoying it as well
but uh there we have it and a big shout
out once again to the St Louis chess
club and Scholastic Center here in St
Louis they just make us feel so very
very welcome and for all uh that you do
thank you as we see Richie and Yvonne
sarishna Yvonne sarich I mean
he's playing Enterprise in chess he's
playing good chess and this last game
the game he just lost against Perugia
that one's really got to hurt because
it's three versus two and this Rook
ending and that move B5 almost the study
light B6 move would have been great uh
he seems to have that expression of woe
is me and look what I've done we've all
been there we know exactly what he's
suffering I think it's better if he
didn't check the game and didn't see
that B6 was drawing yes exactly as we
have a handshake and they are off
uh Vichy pardon me no it's not fishy
exactly I saw Ali reason exchange
variation
with Bishop D3
no Knight C6 uh
and uh those Queen C7 moves and those E7
E6 moves but the traditional Knight F6
and Bishop uh G4 what we Kara Khan
players like to do get our Bishop out
tell the French players that we have a
better Bishop exactly exactly they
should be jealous of our Bishop uh what
do you have for his Mira all right I
just want to mention that wish it's
gonna be wishes third attempt on
cracking the Sicilian night of right and
the two previous ones well were good
result wise but underwhelming in terms
of positions he's gotten from the
opening and Nepal of course is one of
the you know one of the big specialists
in in the night of so where she went
with Knight B3 Bishop G5 a bit of a
modest system right
tries to be solid I would guess after a
loss instead of the bishop E2 Knight F3
what he played before uh turning our
attention to uh Magnus and he is black
against Constantine now
the sad part is for count Constantine uh
he's got this big Target on his back and
he has been losing games and Magnus even
though he's black you know he's playing
for the win because he's trailing by two
points as he's getting ready for the
blitz he's doing something that he he
knows is risky he's playing the king's
Indian because it's an enterprising line
and it's double-edged but the engines
are saying you can't do it these days
but what's what's the Lost move E7 E5
yeah well it's a big surprise because
well you know allowing to exchange the
Queens sometimes happens but after a
short castle and here you know the
engine is very strict it just says take
here take the queen exchange Go castle
long and it's more than opponent in
White's favor so I don't know about this
last move wasn't it like a bit too much
of a provocation I just want to say
Magnus plays so many openings but King's
Indian is not something we see often
from him not at all and and certainly
not this variation of the king's Indian
and like you said uh Miro whoa whoa whoa
I mean E5 once you've short castled yes
possible he confused the move order
I can't imagine that look at Magnus I
think I think he's hiding his eyes could
it could it be that he's trying kind of
not to not to give away the fact that
he's uh the movie is not great let's put
it mildly I I'm trying to figure out
what he might have even had in mind
after castles with the check first of
all you really don't want to put the
bishop and the way uh with Bishop to D7
after you see the move C5 you start to
like look around and say what am I doing
C5 you've got the threat of C6 uh Bishop
takes A6 on tap no no no no
you don't want to move your king king to
d8 like King E8 you go like what am I
doing
um
moves really bad yeah moves like F2 F4
even come into mind with the King stuck
in the center Knight F3 and
um
if Magnus goes down in this round well
it's one of those things in he knows
he's taking risks okay let's stop there
he knows he's taking risk and sometimes
you know you give these guys a position
that they can handle and they handle it
really well again I want to say that
after trades at night to D7 again the
move C5 I find very compelling and
attractive marrow I'm sure the engine is
screaming uh Advantage wide King E8 by
the way well King E8 is also not not the
best response it seems and right you are
yasa C5 practically in every single
variation is the way for white to get
well closely decisive Advantage no there
is for instance C5 right and black
perhaps has to play Bishop to D7 well
well you can capture on A6 that's one
thing but you can also play A3
so you keep everything symmetrical and
just let's compare pieces one by one
right the bishop G7 is silly the Knight
on E6 doesn't do anything and you wish
like black could have castled then
swapped some Rooks on the D file and
then you you know then you reminded your
life but the King has already moved
right so you can't even Castle in this
position so that that's really really
awkward for black
truly uh looks like a terrible opening
in fact let's just take a look around I
want to jump uh to uh the game of Yvonne
um Sarah and Richie report and check
this out
a filador
I think that's the first time we're
seeing Philly during this tournament
from a perk defense move order I want to
say so it he did uh provoke this Knight
to C3 early and Knight t7
um the philadelph
also one of those openings that comes
and goes in fashion you know it hasn't
come back in in a while not in a long
long while uh Bishop f8 Knight C5
uh bring this up to date Miro uh from a
theoretical point of view the philidor
is not a popular defense but uh
statistically speaking is white getting
a big advantage in the uh
interestingly not in this specific line
but I believe it has something to do
that if you're playing let's say with a
dangerous opponent you're probably
finding something a bit more solid than
Philly though to play with black right
so those game that I can see in a
database often feature a player with
black having higher ratings so that
that's the opening you try to play you
know to confuse your opponent to play
for a win interestingly after Bishop f8
among other games there is a game of
even sarich who is white which he lost
which he lost even even ichovich and
after wait a second after Knight E6
there is one but quite a decent game
kiril alexenko against ference berkish
so two uh very well-known Grand Masters
through kd1 we are still following this
game uh computer well of course famous
white is usually more space more
kind of more pressure on black Santa and
the key line would be D5 where Knight
takes Pawn takes E5 Knight D7 but I can
imagine this being double-edged yes
white is better but kind of black has
long-term factors on his side as well
right it's like the bishop potentially
might be slightly better for blood for
me I really like the move that Richie
played Queen B6 uh I like this move for
a very concrete reason I want to
sidestep E5 this Rook on D1 uh vis-a-vis
my queen on d8 I really want a site and
doing so with a gain of tempo uh yeah I
might capture that pawn on B2 I like
this move a lot but I understand what
you were saying Miro about D5 as well
but uh Queen B6 I think I would have
been my choice insane Queen B6 to
[Laughter]
fantasy it's how it's how you uh deal
with everything
b2b3 on the board and maybe now we can
go into that d65 variation or Rook no
wait a minute what am I saying hold on
there is a bishop H6 alert my spidey
sense is tingling uh age 694
ah well Knight takes E4 in Europe and I
got it
apparently interrupt but there is okay
to d8 and Bishop H6 it's interesting how
our brain works because I was thinking
the same Bishop H6 Pawn takes H6 is the
move you don't look at at all and then
you realize Queen F6 Bishop G7 you're
dropping the Knight on D4 so it's very
easy to blunder exactly yeah you don't
look at yeah well it's obvious you take
on H6 I take your knight I'm a pawn up
for good right yes you ruined your
kingdom that's how it works yeah that's
how it works but uh not completely
Bishop G7 turns the tables very very
nice
and let's just take a look at Magnus
once again because Constantine did play
the move C5 and after C6 he said you
know what I really want to ruin your
structure for Life Bishop takes Pawn
takes uh White to play
Rook D6 looks desirable Knight F3
developing
exactly Knight F3 developing even the
move F2 F3 just to
stop any ideas that you might have with
maybe H3 just so I can go three and
Knight F3 it looking very very good uh
by the way our tournament leaders take a
look at Fabiano's game exactly where are
you Fabi Fabi versus Ali Reza let's see
what happened this was the Karo with
Bishop to G4 I think this is good news
for Carolina players pretty good Queen
C7
H3 Bishop back Knight H3 I've played
Bishop D7 before
why
that's what I was taught
that that was the answer to H3 yeah but
don't you want to keep your Bishop alive
once the Queen's not on D1 anymore
we keep the bishop on G4 H5 one night's
already on F3 okay keeping the pin that
makes sense but why
okay uh we'll argue about Bishop H5 92
and he took it I I think he he didn't
want to see Bishop F4 arriving with
Tempo so he took on E2 and
very quickly put his Bishop on D6 and hi
G3 was played just to threaten Bishop F4
yep but simply Bishop D6 and now I don't
love that pawn on G3 I'm not yeah it I
think his idea was to encourage the
bishop to land on D6 so he could play
Knight beef like here
uh Bishop takes G3 starts to be
attractive uh not in every line but
Bishop takes G3 the problem I think is
that we have this Intermezzo move Knight
B5 which is why we had to play A6 but
Bishop G3 again I think isofiber's idea
after Queen A4 check
if you play 97 which is or 90 or 96
right that Knight B5
exactly and now you're getting a second
bishop and suddenly the pawn on G3 that
uh is a star an All-Star as the Bishops
defended
and Miro uh jump in on this A6 Queen A4
check it's kind of confusing for me
right you are that that's fabi's idea
and black has to oppose it in two
possible ways you can play Queen D7
exactly and then perhaps white doesn't
have much else but to trade the Queens
which is I believe roughly equal even
though yeah computer
whilst giving white slight plus but not
nothing major but there is more
interesting move arguably more
challenging King to E7 yes the king is
getting stuck in the center but look at
white species as well like if you don't
have Knight B5 and you do not have
Knight B5 because Queen C6 and D6 is is
no longer hanging with a check so Knight
B5 would be a terrible mistake in this
case so after King E7 then your knight
got stuck the queen is it's not clear
what it does yet and if anything black
will later play rookie 8 King f8 uh go
for it official Castle so here compute
even slightly favors black and there was
one key moment in fact because of the H3
Bishop H5 uh G4
seems like it's winning a pawn I don't
think it was a blondie it was rather
sacrificed right G5 white would have uh
won a pawn like this Knight girls Queen
D5 but the line continues like Queen D5
E5 and then against well-prepared
opponent you probably don't want to play
this that's why Fabi decided for 92.
intriguing uh there was a Pawn on offer
right I mean just I just want to make
absolutely sure I heard that by the way
uh Mira I wanted to ask you a question
Queen A4 check
King E7 and if you don't play the move
Knight B5 let's say you just play Knight
C2 for whatever reasons you your knight
on A3 is no longer attractive to you you
didn't want to play Knight B5 and walk
into a pin is Bishop takes G3
something that white has to be concerned
about it I mean again I find myself
attracted to the move and I'm I'm not
sure if I'm just seeing ghosts
but white captures goes King D1 not
clear how you fall if I wanted to play
Sorry King d194 yeah yeah 94. ah Bishop
E3 sorry
not to mention the risk Queen before you
know Queen B7 yes but no no no the point
was I was thinking I was getting Knight
F2 check and I all right I forgot the
fact that the E3 square is defended and
look at it alireza perhaps picked the
wrong one because here last night B5 oh
and in such an awkward circumstance that
[Music]
the Queen's escaping it seems the
Queen's escaping
the queen is escaping right B6 Queen to
A5 one moment instead of Knight B6
mirror sorry right yeah can he play
Bishop G3 there because this is G3 yes
you can and grumpy says Rook to G1
and yeah it's it's strange because like
you're trying to achieve two things at
the same time like attack the king and
trap the queen right right perhaps you
do not have resources to achieve any of
them in this case well at least
according to computer once again I might
be running and this thing might be wrong
but it's right in this case but for sure
when you play the move Knight F6 to D7
it's almost like you're you're luring
your opponent into this Knight B5
because
if you move the queen well why did we
put our Knight on D7 when we could have
put the Knight on C6 and left the Knight
on F6 maybe do so D4 so for sure he had
Ali Reza had this position in mind
is there some moment exactly here Queen
B6 I'm really uh
fighting to understand what he missed
night beaten maybe he just didn't like
King E7 so he thought this was the best
option he had
or he could have played Knight C6 and
just gone into the two Bishops versus
two knights position uh Queen takes A8
once more uh looking at this here takes
Knight C6 Queen Knight C6 Queen A4 and
the queen runs away which is why we went
Knight B6 Queen A5 A5 and on Knight C6
I'll take
exactly we don't have time Knight C6
we'll take okay eight
exactly I mean too many pieces you can
just take on A8 at this point also have
quantifies yeah I'm trying to trap the
queen
takes
how did how does the queen get away
uh a A4 doesn't work I guess C4
C4
uh
and castle
right
um you know what yes sir I used to think
that it might be interestingly how much
time Olive Reza has because it looks
like some deep preparation now if you if
you look at 18 minutes if you look at it
after Castle short computer is far less
convinced convinced yeah so some Rook A8
Queen E1 Knight D5
and look at this position like it gives
plus one for white but isn't it like
doesn't it look like positional
compensation oh it looks like a
tremendous positional compensation
actually from B7 B5 and so on and you
just okay you have this beautiful Knight
on D5 yeah I mean we play beautifully
what do you do I mean we we make Beauty
points maybe we'll lose the game but uh
you know there's something uh fresh
about this uh position alireza
quite the dynamic player but having the
quiet events right but if we look at the
the standing so Dura was always in the
top five and now right our share in
seventh place yeah anything can happen
in this tournament anyone can beat
anyone so true that even search and
Constantine giving away too many points
as there's a big crowded uh top there
um okay I'm sure
that alireza has prepared this exchange
sacrifice it just seems to me like uh
there's something about this uh that
he's playing Knight F6 to D7 and not
King E7
that uh convinces me this is some crap
check uh in Anand Nepal game all right
it looks quite equal I think Nepal
equalized without any problems Bishops
of opposite color okay I agree we have a
backward Pawn on D6 but
very very hard to put any additional
pressure that looks even if you think of
the Pawn on H4 is it over pushed or I
like it it's okay because we we've got a
dark Square Bishop that can easily
defend it should you
cry to pick it off with Rook h3o
thinking that white needs to do
something based on the Move A4 he
doesn't have it immediately but to try
to create a weakness on the king side
Bishop H6
I've seen this I seem to think of this
vashnikov where somehow the bishop
does okay on the G5 score just hanging
out and uh what do you have for us
game so let's let's do that okay indeed
we haven't when we
okay this was once again a Joko piano
uh repeating the Fabi game
a repeat of the Fabi game right where I
think
or there was a D5 there was a D5 yeah
first right yeah okay uh B5 G3
92 and
doubled e pawns somewhat better for
white right
um just because of the pawns yes just
because of the structure uh probably not
enough for a serious Advantage but you
have magnus's position and is Magnus
fighting back
on the clock yes only on the clock right
so well we could say that magnus's idea
worked to an extent lebowlesque is down
to 10 minutes after 13 moves and being
you know well prepared player I doubt in
any other line he would be that low on
time right right but his position is
overwhelming so now pretty much any move
in one of the most natural native tree
moves leads to a serious advantage and
it was which he has played 98 is the
only move right not to drop material and
then you just have to not to blunder The
Rook on D6 a rook D3 Rook D2
plus plus 1.8 1.7 something of this
nature so materials equal and computer
favors white by almost two Pawns
if anything I'm playing Rook D3 because
sometimes I might have a dream of you
know Swinging The Rook to A3 if the
Knight leaves from C3 just to remind our
viewers that Magnus comes into this
round two points behind the tournament
lead which for him means that he's in
contention for first because he was
three points behind earlier this year in
Warsaw Poland
storming back in the blitz right now
he's sharing third but in Poland he was
in the fifth place after the rapid and
then went on three points behind yes
right against Judah
18 Blitz Games he won 11. that's
ridiculous I mean no I mean
yeah that's just completely ridiculous
to to go in in this field and I believe
he went 10 in a row yes oh that's crazy
probably thinking and I can do it again
I can do it again but by the way oh uh
it was an exchange Sacrifice by
it wasn't a blender I mean his idea was
that you take my rook and I've got this
gorgeous C5 Square for a night so I'm
gonna go Knight A4 Knight C5 and I've
got huge
huge uh positional compensation
maybe an unnecessary sacrifice but you
know I gotta tell you I'm sympathetic to
this I I it looks gorgeous
yeah it's a very Sound Decision
understandable you know from humans
perspective right you want to capitalize
on your initiative and so on this looks
like a good way and what I want to say
kudos to lupulasco I mean it's clearly
not his tournament and he's not shy of
sacrificing material against black he's
not backing down that's exactly right
but the other thing you've got to say
for from Constantine's point of view if
he goes on to win this game by crushing
Magnus it goes into his book of best
games
and that's not inconsiderable one of the
worst tournaments maybe of his life but
also on his best wins if he can get it
now he's just played the move Knight D2
he didn't include Knight C5 which I'm
wondering why this is this is a little
bit strange because Knight C5 was much
stronger yeah it's just so obvious and
compelling that you want but again from
uh White's point of view I mean he he
thinks Knight C5 is Unstoppable he
thinks he'll go Knight C5 and Knight to
C4 but the immediate Knight C5 was
better Miro was much better and much
figured out why because okay after
Knight C5 you can't really connect the
Rooks you need a setup King F7 and
Bishop E6 which was reachable in the
game and that's exactly what Magnus did
after Knight D2 he could have played
Bishop E6 at once or as he did in the
game King F7 but just look at at the
position of the Knight C5 how do you
ever connect
the only move is Bishop C8 after which
D7 wins correct so Knight C5 would would
have put him in almost a stalemate
position and then you can do whatever
you please you can lift the Rook first
not to ever block the D file yes like a
plan would be to go Rook D3 and then
move the Knight whenever you like it to
move uh so 95 I believe was a much
stronger move but I think it would have
been met by Rook d8 by the way we do
have a trade on E6 Knight B3
um was that a relief for Magnus if he
plays Rook d8 Chad Chad and King F7
and at least he's he's getting it seems
like he's getting rid of this D6 Pawn
you'd be surprised but the engine goes
after the after the repetition here
with Knight B7 which I believe will not
happen you're getting ambitious after
this such sacrifices but right but yeah
but that's because Bishop fate is a big
threat and and D7 uh Rook a B8 first to
stop Knight B7 and then eventually
Bishop of eight and you drop the D7 Port
yikes Magnus fighting his way back in
yes in the game Fabi against firusha we
have that position that the entire
sequence that we calculated wow okay so
he did go for this whole exchange
sacrifice so after Queen takes C6 Rook
A8 is trapping the lady and we have to
make room and that was why we play a
move that we really don't want to play
which is C3 C4 takes attacks The Rook on
H1 castles and Queen went to H5 Knight
D5 Bishop D2
um how does the engine assess this uh
exchange sacrifice it gives a plus to
White yeah plus to White okay plus
0.90.8 however if I'm looking at the
lines what white has to play there's
nothing convincing it's not like white
breaks through or something basically
hovers around so it could be that even
the modern you know very strong engines
tend to underestimate at least practical
aspect of Black's compensation exactly
so for example after Bishop D2 Miro if I
just boldly play B5 yeah you could and
maybe start with G6 I don't know that
that's what the bot suggests go G6 go B5
right and just oh around it seems like
some Queen B7 Bishop f8 I can see at
some point like putting it on G7 yeah I
was thinking also of even Queen to B6 uh
whether the bishop does get fee and
shadowed or not but just this idea that
this Knight on D5 remains uh you know
like a Thor you know over the position
the engine has no respect for that
[Laughter]
uh with uh Vichy let's just just check
in
um somehow there's a D6 Pawn missing
because he sacrificed the D6 Pawn
you just like this he's going to Rook D2
next move ah
thank you for that
not necessarily next move okay King G7
uh and he wants Rook to D2
which means I may have to play Rook to
D1
and then we're going to get the opposite
color Bishops okay very good mattress
did not play Rook d8 as was suggested by
the engine he played Rook B8
was that inaction no he does have a rook
on d8 no it wasn't B8 excuse me excuse
me so it went aha he didn't go Rook d8
right away he went Rook B8 then came
check what's going on with this game
guys I don't understand what is going on
because now
according to the machine D6 D7 just wins
plus three wins as is plus three for
white
wow
it's not that easy to comprehend but
perhaps perhaps Rooks are getting stuck
now he didn't play it oh the D7
Rooks traps The Rook so Rooks are
paralyzed and this you can't move your
king you can't go King you can't
approach the Pawn King E7 runs into
Bishop C5 King E6 runs into Knight C7
yes 97 looks good because he's about to
pick up A7 as well okay let's see he
played Knight C7 on the board yeah
what the boat has to say and if you
capture on A7 Bishop f8 Bishops all of a
sudden it's already already black who is
better for whatever reason rugby seven
no it slowly confiscating this D6 Pawn
wait a minute wait a minute hold on
because we have to calculate A4
no no you're threatening Rook takes C7
and Bishop takes C5 sorry I was thinking
that black was going to go Rook to d8
and take on D6 and by that time I wanted
to make a coronation uh but Rook takes
C7 oh wow D7 was really killing block oh
that is a position there's nothing black
can do pieces can't move but that is a
move that you aspire to play in such
positions you just want to paralyze the
Rooks so that there is no Rook B8
there's no Rook C8 you can't double and
it's remarkable that Constantine didn't
play that move it's interesting that a
Magnus has taken his time here because
if you play Rook B8 yeah I was going to
take on A7 with the 10 with the tempo
thank you for that right so you're right
he did pause but he did end up playing
Rook on A8 to C8 so once again Bishop
takes Bishop f8 Rook C5 Rook C7 and uh
Miro if I go he's done it if I go B4
defending four at the end of the line uh
yeah you won't let me let me see it and
we have Bishop f8 yeah before Group C to
d8
yep and the best you can do is Bishop to
B6
don't ask me why
thanks D6 Rook takes D6
and if you take with the Rook okay this
is something if you take with the Rook
that computer claims white to be better
after a four it's a marginal age so
apparently white wins back the exchange
and black somehow manages to stop the
pawn in some long variation so in order
for black to try to be better kind of he
has to take with the bishop Knight B5
Rook D7 I would assume this is very
close to the Fortress Yeah to get the
pawn to A5 and they've played those
moves as expected and now this is the
moment of truth in fact rugby sorry B4
is the only move after Rook dice exactly
and one thing Magnus does have a huge
time Advantage he has four times as much
time four wow that's 20 minutes against
five uh Constantine has been in playing
slowly and getting himself in the time
travel once you get into time travel the
blunders come very very quickly let me
just go around the horn a little bit and
go to the game of fobby uh picking up
because again this is this is beautiful
uh to my eyes this is beautiful uh
imbalance going on here and I'm a big
fan of what I don't Define of the night
on D5 and again the engine is probably
laughing at me and saying uh White is
better and everything else but uh in
Practical human play I I like what uh
farouza has done vishi uh
looks like they're heading towards it
very equal middle game very equal
G7 interesting that he didn't trade
Rooks and go Queen D6 there and then
pull once too
keep pieces on the board
he's not worse no no it's not uh let's
check in on Yvonne sarich versus Richie
oh when we left it he did play that
whole sequence by the way with Queen B6
and D5
so you get those kind of French defense
like positions
and you're on E5 is really dominating
yeah but on the other hand wait a minute
we've got rid of our light squared
Bishop which is you know hey something
uh
and if I can get in C5 Knight G5 Knight
E4 life could be good what is white
who's who's unturned King HD is black to
move black to move
uh but what if I play F4 and then
I don't know how yet but I need to get
my knight on G6
okay one way to go uh my turn I get to
play nights it's night night to G5 first
so I do I am eyeballing the E4 Square
ah you told me that you were you were
reaching for your F fund that you only
moved it to F3 okay C5
isn't uh isn't this
fine I don't know
I mean I I've seen I've seen too many
victories uh games a lot of Victor korch
noise games where he would double on the
half open f file and he he beat a lot of
players I must say on the black side
here
so still anything can happen in this
game absolutely and for Richie uh he's
looking to try to beat Yvonne sarich
Evan struggling today he's in ninth
position right right but rich is sharing
third so if he wins exactly he can
definitely jump in the
maybe even catch Bobby or an apple yeah
he's got an imbalanced position maybe
he's taking too many risks but well see
how it goes and let me just jump to Duda
versus good cash because when we left it
it was those doubled e-pawns they're
still there they're still there it's a
feature it's not a bug huh
okay Rook
um I think the only way black gets rid
of those double pawns is by losing them
and then he'll have no weaknesses once
you get rid of her at them
um
yeah okay so should I yeah exactly
should I be playing Knight B1 and Knight
C3 I'm not sure what I should be doing
with my pieces this night maneuvering
it's possible and the clocks is that a
factor between these two not yet they
both have 12 11 minutes
okay as we see
this is Ivan Richards game and he's
played Queen to E7 none of that Knight
G5 uh business but uh over to you Miro
and you've got the Magnus yes some
breaking news right I mean I was
streaming 10 minutes ago five minutes
ago how lupoleski is winning against
Magnus right and guess what the game
turned upside down so once again we
already know that yeah the worst is over
for Magnus after this get this moment
right before rook cd8 and Constantine
couldn't find Bishop B6 which is not
intuitively easy to find right A4 and
then just swapped everything on D6
A5 but this is this is winning for black
now winning who's the only move Rook D7
which has been played 1986 and Rook D4
not only Rook D4 King E8 Works Rook D4
works so
but hold on you you're Rook D4 I get it
but isn't that a pawn go you know if I
go King C2 King C3 Knight C5 the point
is like he activates the rook and then
he marches with the King no he doesn't
take the pawn okay sorry or eat rather
because it's a computer line right uh
the king will go to stop the pawns after
King C2 it's King to E7
King to C3 yeah King to E7 King to C3
came to D6 Knight to C5 and then you are
in a square of this Pawn so you can go
Rook D1 okay not exactly in the Square
but you have Rook A1 in if you need it
right right and Magnus has 20 minutes to
figure out best way to win this
right So eventually it claims that the
king's gonna stop the pawn and then the
Rook is gonna Feast on White's Kings and
White's King side of course
gotcha what a turnaround well uh Magnus
pushed the envelope there the the risk
looks like it's going to pay off
but it really played with it he's
playing with fire no question about it
uh in this game uh well let's see where
I kind of like an apple game I know we
kept saying it's just a dead road that
equal but is it that simple because net
was playing on those black squares
as in maybe nepo has some maybe he has
something
he just buy the move Queen B6 by the way
it's it's kind of awkward from White's
point of view because
what is my queen doing on my age right
should I shouldn't I be playing Queen E8
or you know
I want to do something active myself he
played Queen C8 F6
Queen C8 oh and if you go Rook F1 okay
you can have a tactic Bishop E1 no no
immediately
immediately Bishop V1 that is cute but I
want to keep the Rooks on the board okay
oh no
I'm sorry could you sign my score sheet
for me you know as a momentum but if you
had played rookie one and the same idea
right then it's just you you're you're
doing great I get it no no see I get it
uh Queen C8 Rook S6 you can play Bishop
F3 I think it's forced actually I have
to block you but having said that I am
Tempo in the the the bishop Queen C8
Bishop F4 so for all of that
chewing and throwing uh where he didn't
play Rook takes D1 we got a position
where
but now he wants to get his Queen on the
first or second Rank and White's King is
uncomfortable very uncomfortable exactly
true that
so like if we take Rook takes C6 yep
Queen takes the six because White Queen
doesn't have an easy way to come back
yeah so what do you play here
yeah I I I I hear you uh loud and clear
if I play a move for example like Bishop
F1 giving you a free hand
uh
if you do drop in Queen I can
take and take and maybe
I can play Bishop C1 here and just go
after your Pawns
training's working
Bishop C1 okay C4 I trade I'm probably
worse
uh it should be equal of course right
it's just some tiny little chances I get
it I get it and it's rapid after all
exactly and the clock time time and it's
down to five and a half minutes and I
post 13 and a half exactly
uh let's jump to the game of fobby for a
moment because he's he's managed to do
something exchange the Bishops well well
went for that Bishop trade and I must
say I I find that confounding I would
have thought that the bishop on
being shadowed or on the F6 diagonal was
better for
black to keep it
and we've got a lot of Mo's marrow not
necessarily
that Fabi has made any progress but the
the assessment must be better for white
now yeah it is and possibly he did I'm
not quite sure about this Bishops
exchange exactly because it seems that
it allows white a little a little bit
more activity because now yeah like Rook
D1 we've seen Queen A4 rookie one of
course is a normal move but computer
already shouts at something like Rook to
E5
and I guess the point is that the Knight
on D5 was an absence of you know bishop
and in fact kind of not enough pieces to
have a real content play the Knight 25
is very static it's a nice piece I get
it but once white gets the G Pawn going
you know the knight from D5 is kind of
not close enough to the king so that's
pretty much what computers doing I mean
some rookie five rookie one rookie four
starts pushing those pawns and claims
that white is better and in fact I'm yet
to see any active idea for black so
black plays in sort of a fortressy way
right keep the Knight on D5 keep
everything protected but let's see how
long this fort is going to hold
intriguing
um going to the Magnus position for just
a moment is I mean when we left it you
know I with understanding we thought
okay uh
you know you
we've got this Knight on C5 and your
kings in the Square but this one check
huh yes yes uh King B2 instead of King
B3
because
if you take Roxy Five I know it looks
winning but it might not be winning
I think we were looking more like this
and oh wait a minute we're not in the
Square anymore uh
and I just missed that earlier so he
played Rook check and he played King C7
in order to meet A6 with King b or King
B6
oh my uh just a draw has been agreed uh
a repetition between Fabi and ferrugia
and well Fabi goes into the Blitzen of
excellent shape uh having performed so
well sorry you were about to there's a
very cute line here in magnus's games
played King B2 okay black takes Rook
takes C5 okay if I take it's dead lost
but I have eight six here no way
right and that
wow so the whole point is A7
takes
King A3 Rook P1 King A2
wow that is pretty
Purdy you're not stopping me oh my so
Rook takes C5 A6 oh that is so easy to
miss uh Miro uh
wow I can only confirm that Nas is
absolutely right wow yes Rook C1 was the
best wasn't the best move but it was in
fact a blunder from Magnus before before
it he was winning after Rook C1 indeed
King B2 would have made the draw but
would have made it a draw right but I
mean seriously How likely are you How
likely are you to consider this wow and
yeah it's a king what a trick though
into C7 and I think this last move kind
of confirms that yeah it's one of those
positions where if you're told you have
a draw then it's easy to find right but
you don't expect you have a drop you
know look for it and Knight C5 to E6
check King B7 so no the ace a pawn is no
longer an issue so it's all about Knight
f8 and Rook G1 I'm assuming nine takes
H7 right well to I I have to play Knight
f8 I mean and just hope that I'm
scooping up as many pawns as I can
um let me say that you want some stupid
G instead yeah well we do have Knight f8
H6
if you take maybe you should be playing
Knight D7 by the way if you take
well maybe I can defend Knight H4
exactly
although the fact they still have this
C6 Bond that's going to be very
meaningful I'm sure the Rook is going to
outplay the uh the the night in these
endings but Knight f8 on the board so
once again Fabi versus Ali Reza they
made a repetition I just want to see how
they did it at the very end I think it
was just Rooks going back and forth
yeah just uh a repetition interesting uh
well
probably appreciated the night on D5
even though the the Bots do not
and another games definitely it's almost
over
by that I mean a draw
yeah uh so did did we yes he did play
the move Bishop C1 and we did cc4 and
they did go right into that line and
Vichy slightly worse after all but uh
but a draw undoubtedly
and let's go with the game of Richie for
just a moment where are you Ivan sarich
Ritchie
again very good so black never played C5
like you wanted hmm
well this is just enjoyable kind of like
white is playing a risk-free position
here and if you get H5 Knight G6 check
and a Pawn on G6
that's just that's a dream position yeah
that's just not not a lot of fun that
pawn on g6s so why it feels to me like
white has a considerable Edge
uh just because you're not getting any
counter play Blackness to passively
defend but it's very unpleasant exactly
it's not everybody's cup of tea to
defend passengers
game because his last move Knight F4 was
interesting
which dude I did not accept I'm not sure
why
can we ask
there's a rook hanging on A7 oh but E5
am I taking two nights yeah
yeah but what's the body count after
E5 I've won a pawn
um no I have Queen A3
2 check oath I beg your pardon uh crazy
stuff uh but uh let's pause for a moment
and jump to Zagreb and uh Christian what
do you have for us Christian
thanks uh Yasser we do have one of the
potential uh leaders going into the
blitz section most likely one of the
co-leaders going into uh the blitz
section Fabiano caruana with us Fabi uh
welcome back to the show tell us a bit
about today's rounds and how are you
feeling going into the blitz action yeah
there's a little bit of a shaky day
I I guess I could have lost my first two
games but I finished one and a half
points very fortunately
um first game was really tough I think
he sacrificed the piece I think he was
played brilliantly
and you know then he in the
complications a long time he lost
control
but but I was really in danger then I
think in Zion I was just dead lost
basically I kind of mixed up the
the line a little bit I'm not super
familiar with the line and it's
everything kind of looks the same in
this line so he knew the line better
than me uh he got a winning position but
he wasn't super easy and and I also
defended that one in the last game I
don't know
I feel like I played pretty dubiously in
the opening but uh then he sacrificed
The Exchange completely unnecessarily
and then I I don't know if I could have
maybe played on but I saw no ideas and I
decided not to okay it was a good day
not to push my life just to interrupt
you for a second sorry I did win his
game against Richie report quite an
important result for him he was
struggling in today's rounds uh what is
it about your mentality because you had
this type of situations against Richie
report and against Google cash very
similar in which you can take the drop
but you can also play on in one it paid
off in one it didn't but still you were
showing very clear fighting Spirit how
is your mentality tell us a bit about
that well I thought against kukash like
at the moment when I could have taken a
draw and decided to play on I think it
was completely risk-free uh and against
Richie I was Wireless winning and uh so
of course I'm not going to take a draw
then maybe I I
I kind of lost control I had to make
these like split-second decisions of
should I maybe try to clean it up or
continue gambling and that didn't work
out but against kukash I think it was a
completely uh sober decision
okay he has a Perpetual but that's the
best he has he he definitely can never
win this end yet and and he still has to
prove it so I think that was just a good
decision but in general of course I am
trying to fight and take my chances
um but I also try not to overextend Too
Much which is what I often have done in
the past but trying to keep a bit more
control here Bobby uh congratulations on
a good rapid portion we'll see you
tomorrow in the Blitz
thank you uh Christian and indeed uh
well done Fabi as he hopes to go into
the blitz portion of the event
type for first or clear first and Magnus
uh by the way is scooping up pawns and
uh well yeah the it's no contest in this
night versus Rook position so Magnus uh
cruising to Victory and it wasn't it
wasn't a smooth ride as he was
definitely losing out a couple times a
couple of times out of the open it was
always the move D7 that had to be played
yes uh absolutely Knight C5 check King
A7 just hanging about do you think the
strong players get more lucky more often
yes yeah right yeah I really do I really
do and uh I have seen it so often in uh
games of Kasparov and karpov where it's
like
they that they're worse and somehow they
land on their feet so so often I don't
know if it's luck or it's just opponents
respecting them so much
and not having confidence that I can
defeat you exactly
and we have three games still going
but vicious game is about to end in a
draw
they're just as
uh
yeah but I I like this decision very
much by Anand right here when you know
because there's only one problem that
white has is this Pawn on F2 and this
Pawn on H4 is really annoying so you
play the move G4 and if you you say if
you don't play on poisson I'm just going
to play kg2 you've got nothing but that
trade just makes life a little bit
easier like you can breathe a little bit
more the pawn on H4 is gone it's not
suffocating and this game is going to be
drawn despite the fact there's a five
minutes to ten minutes uh yeah it's a
pretty simple draw
very much so and how is kokesh doing
against Judah that is the big question
uh Miro uh jump in and tell us how is
gukash doing against Duty well that was
really a lot of maneuvering which is
hard to understand even with the
computer help right but then this Knight
F4 indeed deserved to be taken
it wasn't straight up winning but after
Queen B3 is that more precise than Queen
C3 right Rook takes A7 E5 white would be
material up
that as simple as that yes a computer is
not depressed right it says black can
fight so a check
King goes here ef6 Queen F6
perhaps it will be hard to win but it's
clearly better for white the the the two
knights are better by the way we do have
a in the vicious game a draw agreed uh
the two players
um and the current position uh Miro of
gukesh
oh magnus's game is over as well he yeah
he won the game yeah as we expected
what a chance local missed
wow he sure did and for Magnus that
means that he's keeping I am getting
closer close just one point behind now
right when uh when you think about the
Polish
he has 18 games to catch up with the
litters exactly if he has a good day
tomorrow
um
sorry back to you in the the glucash
game uh mirror so what's the evaluation
you want to know yes
um well I can give you my expert opinion
that white is up a pawn however
plus 0.1 in if you consider the machine
and it
it's some weird thing a ghost Knight A6
something exactly what you're told not
to do right right the Knight A6 but
apparently if you push the pawn you
immediately lose the full pawn and it's
it's equal material so after Knight A6
both sides start making some
strange looking moves Knight to D7
Knight B3 and then eventually something
that I can understand King goes towards
the center it's yeah it's very close to
equality so maybe white somehow manages
to keep this double extra Pawn but
cannot really capitalize on this and
Miro help our audience understand the
inside joke you just shared there and
your expert expert opinion
the story comes from it's a beautiful
story I actually don't quite remember
but I think it was about it was first of
all the time when the games would be
adjourned so we are talking classical
time control enough to say four hours of
play the game would be adjourned and
someone would write down the move it we
put in an envelope and the game would be
continued next day or few days after
sometimes right and I think it was like
on a television or something right and
yeah so it was like it was a reporter
who had no idea apparently about how
chess works and so on so he asked
someone and not to not to look like a
fool he wanted to bring up a big name
and said in opinion of Master x white is
up upon and we yeah we take all the
responsibility away for counting the
pawns ourselves right right but this was
I thought from times of the Soviet Union
and the American players all felt that
everybody in the Soviet Union understood
chess and this idea that we needed the
expert Master's opinion we're up upon
right I mean and to complete those
rights yeah expert opinions and let's
jump to Zagreb
Magnus going into today's rounds it felt
nearly similar to what happened in
Poland you were trailing by quite a few
points what was the goal uh on how many
points were you thinking of finishing
today's rounds the rapid rounds
um no I I mean I thought the first game
would be difficult and then the next two
I would have a good chance to win so uh
overall of course plus two is pretty
good and that's exactly what happened
and especially this final game it was a
bit shaky it felt at some point like
that exchange sacrificed by him
definitely it felt uncomfortable for you
yeah I mean
I don't know what I was thinking in the
opening I was thinking E5 um like there
are similar lines for instance with
Bishop E2 uh immediately
um like
here E5 is a move I mean it's not a
great move but
um I I was I was thinking that
um I was thinking that uh you know with
the 1986
on the bishop and E3 at least no Bishop
G5 is coming in one go so I thought like
for a moment I was being clever but I
just missed uh I just missed C5 so this
whole thing was yeah this was this was
terrible and here after C6
um I don't
also when I I I realize here I realized
quickly that group D6 is really strong
otherwise it's
maybe kind of kind of playable I mean
search positions
I've seen I've seen them before and with
the bishop there and
and
yeah well exactly the bishop there you
do have some long-term potentials
um and I think there was this yeah
I mean I I played I played knights in
Bishop E6 which was insane uh I was
focused on the night going to C4 so
first I I didn't really understand what
he was doing since I thought like I'm
I'm doing fine now and then immediately
as I went Bishop D E6 I saw that he
could bring the Knight to B3 in London I
thought yeah now I'm probably probably
lost again
um
but yeah I mean whatever a lot of things
happened later but it was this also this
moment I'm not sure if you if you guys
caught it at one point after the move um
I think it was Rook to D1 I'd C5 Rook C1
he had this move King to B2 oh my God
oh that's so disgusting yeah that's
really disgusting of course uh uh of
course I wanted to to sack The Exchange
and just win easily but
um yeah I just have Asics
some sort of a study like yeah I mean
that's oh yeah that was
super careless
I think like in general I was just yeah
not in the right State of Mind for for
the last game like I was really really
happy with the win against Duda I
thought I calculated that very well uh
but then yeah in the last game
last game still everything is uh well
that finished uh well and tomorrow
perhaps one point behind the leaders
going into 18 rounds and Blitz
certainly yeah
[Music]
Nepal Drew as well yeah yeah uh that's
um obviously considering the
circumstances that's pretty
pretty reasonable uh
um
I think a lot can happen a lot can
happen now in in Blitz
um
I think alireza is certainly the one who
has the highest potential of anyone
um
but
yeah it's it's it's hard to say
um both the other and Fabi will probably
need to do something they've never done
before in order especially if like if
either well especially if I have a if I
have a good blister they will need to do
something they've really never done
before in order to to win but
um but that's not impossible of course
um otherwise yeah I'm happy to be in a
reasonable position now um
today I felt a lot better so like any
way that I would not play well today
no worries well definitely you have some
inspiring Bliss performances to get that
inspiration for tomorrow go get some
rest we'll see you tomorrow yeah thank
you
thank you Magnus and thank you Christian
indeed once you see Rook C5 Asics he was
disgusted
the two loneliest players in the
tournament uh on stage all by themselves
uh Duda versus goo cash we've seen a
repetition uh who's playing
well my guess would be that now it's
black because what happened since the
last visit the sea Pawn left the board
right white used to have Seaport Pawn in
this
in this position those nights yeah the
picturesque position of those nights
here
uh if you were going to tell me that uh
players losing the ending due to the
double pawns I would have thought it was
black because remember back here it was
the double pawns the black had the
double the E pawns and now it's white
with the double e pawns but somehow he
has lost his C pawn and now we do see
gukash is the one who's saying I would
like to play on playing Knight A4 King
what are we doing now see are we are we
trying to finagle our way into G6 I
would play more
relatively and defend my E3 fonts so
bring the king back
it was a bluff
we're not playing uh in King H5 black
also has King F7 so I'm not sure going
that far
a good point yeah King F7 Cuts you off
in the past right
but he is going for it though King F7
yes King H5 King S7 here we need to play
Knight d8 check Mira we're not playing
Knight d8 heck we have a problem uh yeah
but how to get there exactly honestly I
have a problem because whenever I look
at those engine lines it says zeros and
the moves you know the moves are pretty
much random one of them is is G4 and I
wish you wish you had the Knight only
four in this position right right but
yeah but the very next move you go to E4
he goes G5 so in fact G4 might not be a
bad idea you just trade more pawns right
and there is one little trick in this
position when black will still be you
know pulling up but will run out of King
side pawns you could actually sacrifice
Knights for the pawn right one age and
two knights cannot Checkmate the king
exactly
so G4 94 G5 yeah but that's not the only
not the only way you can you can just
return back but it's so unnatural to
voluntarily put the King on H5 and Pawn
on G4 which by the way has been played
GeForce played on the board wow
and is that there's Not Afraid at all uh
they're both under one minute they
calculated with a few seconds
either both under a minute huh so there
will be relying on their increments now
so 94 G5
changes happen and then
less pawns are on the board
okay good cash is a legendary play
because how do you stop yourself from
playing Knight E4
uh
uh yeah G5 finally on the board you can
probably take with either Pawn or the
King on G5
my instinct would be to take with the
pawn but uh King takes means that you do
have H5 and H6 to trade more pawns if
you would like so maybe King takes G5 is
is simpler he's done kingtex G5
Knight E4 check because H5 H6
potential is there for that Knight to D5
whoa for a second I thought E4 was a
fork on the knights
yeah optical illusion right yeah
but but you would really upset your
opponent if you played E4 followed by E
four takes D3 that would that would
really be upsetting
and just as a reminder to everybody it's
Blitz baby starting tomorrow we'll have
two days of exciting Blitz exactly nine
rounds double round robin nine nine
games on Saturday nine games on Sunday a
playoffs we'll talk about playoffs if it
comes up 18 games is not enough then you
also need to play the playoffs exactly
exactly
yeah I thought it was kind of funny
there with uh with Christian that he was
explaining that Magnus
uh could catch up
with only 18 games
like what only 18 games yeah Magnus
feels quite confident he was saying that
Fabian nepo need to do something they've
never done before right that that he he
assumes that he will be having a very
good result uh so they will have to play
extremely well to maintain their first
uh
is a favorite in Blitz yes but he's so
behind on the points from the rapid
portion that he really needs to win 10
games in a row exactly and I take this
game's heading I I just don't see how
the players avoid the draw now Knight
takes uh season they don't they don't
they don't they don't they will agree a
draw no exactly
and we're gonna sit to remove repetition
absolutely
well a very exciting uh
series of Rapid chess games come to a
close and uh two players type of first
going into the Blitz nepo and Fabi nepo
and Fabi
were
joined first coming into today with
Vichy but vishi fell off the pace
but nepo is definitely the most
disappointed player today because he had
a huge advantage against Papi and that
was a big game because Fabby saved as
you saw in the interview with Christian
Fabi was the first to admit that he
messed it up that he really messed up
his French defense and he was in
distress but let's jump to Christian and
Zagreb for some final thoughts of wow a
really great rapid
portion
well it was an amazing day of Rapid
chess and as I've mentioned at the
beginning of the show never count Magnus
Carlson out of contention and he proved
that today with just a brilliant
performance two and a half out of a
three five points in the rapid scoring
system out of six that's pretty good and
he's only one point behind we know what
happened in Poland we remember what
happened in Poland and I have to say if
you are Fabian Nepal you definitely have
to be looking over your shoulder right
now with Magnus closely behind you but
also alireza and that's my pick maybe we
can show the picks that we have up to
this point but alireza I still have
faith in my boy and I think we're going
to see a lot of exciting chess in the
blitz round coming tomorrow Anastasia I
actually was watching this following
this game which I'm sure was followed
also by all Indian fans today between
vision
you know and I thought of like I got
this thought that VC actually erased the
bista
and actually we were talking about this
game before the tournament and he was
telling that he will try just to play
with species but you know it's really
hard to play against one of the best
players in the world
who is also let's say one of the most
talented people chess players in the
world and now I mean when cookies
actually won this game you could see
that yeah he was like so nervous and
emotional
um I managed to quote him you know after
the end of the game I managed to ask him
a few questions and we you can find all
those videos in our social media
accounts and Instagram please follow us
in grantchester and you will see lots of
more information there and I mean I
think this was one of the key matches
today and that's why I spent so much
time also watching it and speak about it
now no it was indeed and it was I have
to say a terrifying moment to realize
how good gookish is at only 17 years of
age to beat your Mentor your idol the
idol of a whole nation let's be honest
everybody knows who he is not only chess
players everybody in the nation
is and to beat him at only 17 years of
age is just an incredible accomplishment
I have to say
um but uh I think the producers want to
show us something and here we have our
predictions
oh what what do we have here okay I was
robbed that's all I've got to say dude I
should have had much more points I'll
keep quiet actually
yes sir but you know I'm hoping that he
will do very good tomorrow because it's
Blitz days
we were on the same page I see I see all
right
we're still in it Nazi don't don't worry
that that last round last by Richie uh
yeah that's gonna hurt and miro's like
the points pick for themselves
exactly exactly I don't know what you
guys discussing I mean look at the final
standings yeah well let's show this the
final standings of the rapid here as uh
what we've just seen the ninth and final
round of Rapid chest right we have two
co-leaders Fabiano caruana and Yanni
promise you with 12 points and uh Magnus
saying you guys have better play the the
blitz of your lives because I'm coming
for you he's in clear third with 11
points and then sharing a fourth place
uh with 10 points two Indian
Grandmasters Anan and gukesh exactly
York Pick uh farouza at night
and Dennis is Big also Richie a big
shout out once again to our three uh
sponsors Croatia is full of life
Foundation as well as a super United and
of course here in St Louis the St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center thank
you for everything you do you make us
feel so welcome here at uh St Louis and
back to you mirror for final thoughts
wrapping up today's broadcast uh well as
for today I think everything was set all
the players who played well were
mentioned I just want to warn that
tomorrow please join I mean it's going
to be Blitz it's completely different
animal it's a different speed different
Rhythm right only two seconds increments
so when they get into time trouble it's
all messed up so really I'm looking
forward to a lot of excitement tomorrow
and the day after tomorrow absolutely
thank you mirror and well how's your
Blitz game by the way you like Blitz I
do but I can't compare myself
I love Blitz I grew up as a blitz player
myself I think it's the most popular
form of Chess throughout the world you
can go to Parks all over the world and
you'll see them smashing the clocks
thank you so much for joining us it was
a pleasure and we hope you'll join us
over the weekend tell your friends where
you're hanging out that's just wonderful
it's great it's great see you tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited